this video is brought to you by keeps
All Eyes seem to be squarely on the
future of Dragon Ball these days and how
could it not with Dragon Ball Super's
manga releasing tons of new material
consistently a brand new movie just
having been released and a rumored
sequel series to Super on the horizon
there's a lot for newer and older fans
of the series to enjoy and yet all I
could think about this week was this
that's right this week I was reading
through some of the best Original Dragon
Ball has to offer and no I'm not talking
about Raditz through the Majin Buu I'm
talking about the original arcs that
comprise the beginning of this story or
as I like to affectionately refer to it
as oh my God this is like 40 of the
freaking Story how is no one seen this
it's amazing but yes uh you heard me
right most people haven't seen about 40
of the story The Red Ribbon Army has
returned Daniel
stretching from the pilaf Saga all the
way through to Piccolo Junior it's
easily one of the most underrated
stories in all of Manga and Anime that I
know of and with the majority of people
looking ahead to the future of the
series I figured it should be my
responsibility to show people where this
series came from and why it's widely
considered by those that have read it
some of the absolute best material this
Series has to offer that's right I'm
talking funny I'm talking action-packed
I'm talking hey Mom go to the store to
get some tissues because Goku's making
me cry and you know what they didn't
need to create a Multiverse tournament
or make constant callbacks to itself to
get a reaction from its audiences either
this is an immortal story with Legacy
action comedy and sadness and quite
simply this original tale set the
foundation for the story that will go on
to capture the hearts and minds of
millions across the world for decades to
come which is why I'm so nervous writing
this video this is a cultural Touchstone
of a story and I want to do it justice
so what are we waiting for I'm totally
not Mark and this is my review of Akira
toriyama's underrated and undefeated
Dragon Ball
[Music]
truth be told I'm actually unreasonably
excited to get into this with all of you
today so let's dive into the very first
Saga that catapult the Dragon Ball into
Japanese pop culture I'm talking about
the 23 chapter long pilaf Saga
yes
god it feels so strange but amazing to
be back in this world with new eyes
after having spent the last decade
learning about storytelling one of the
first things that immediately became
apparent to me was how effective
Toriyama was at characterization
particularly with both Goku and Bulma
right off the bat utilizing paneling
Framing and dialogue to push this aspect
of his story you can absolutely tell
that this isn't his first manga either
while the story is very simple it is so
for specific measured reasons the first
chapter kicks off her story with the
famous and effective first meeting of
Goku and his soon-to-be lifelong friend
Bulma and I call this scene effective
because while Toriyama has made plenty
of questionable writing decisions
throughout his long career I don't
believe he could have handled this first
chapter any better the priority of the
first chapter typically is to introduce
us to and bond us with the main
characters of The Ark and immediately
Toriyama highlights how these two
characters he created are exact
opposites of each other Goku is
physically strong but innocent and naive
Bulma is physically weak in comparison
but is much more experienced and on
another intellectual level to Goku
altogether with their first decisions
made in this story not wasting any time
in their characterization acting as a
window into who these people really are
Goku is inquisitive with some shockingly
friendly and naivety thrown into the mix
his first action is to attack and use
his Brawn to overcome the obstacle all
the while Bulma after reflexively going
for her gun a mechanical enhancement her
first thought is to try and manipulate
Goku into handing over his Dragon Ball
and to help her on her Quest this is our
starting point and it tells us so so
much about who these characters are and
what possibilities might lie ahead in
their story together
[Music]
furthermore I was delighted to see
toriyama's brilliant use of paneling
used to reinforce this Avenue of
characterization more traditionally I
really appreciate how Toriyama uses his
layouts to build a visitation for a page
turn this is a minor example and I'll
show more as the stakes rise over the
course of the story but this page with
Goku overlooking a cliff it's a tall and
narrow panel with Goku pictured quite
small atop of it and it's given this
real estate to tell us quite simply that
this Cliff is extremely tall and on that
same page Goku is shown not to care
about that as he jumps down with ease
communicating that this isn't a normal
everyday boy it's a small choice but it
sure as hell beats someone lecturing to
us that he's some freakishly strong kid
and on the topic of visuals the first
chapter has one of my favorite panels in
all of the story this one
this image on its own to me acts as a
microcosm of what Goku will do in the
story moving forward his outward
appearance will make someone think one
thing and then they will quickly be
taken off guard by something they did
not expect from him Bulma up until this
point and even on this very panel's page
has been contemplating and formulating a
plan to exploit Goku she's seen it all
before and she feels like she knows
exactly what's coming and as Goku
proceeds into his modest living quarters
Bulma doesn't find someone living there
with him she doesn't find anything she
might be expecting instead she sees a
small boy earnestly praying before a
totem representing his deceased grandpa
Gohan the four-star ball I love this
image Bulma does continue to try and
exploit Goku's understanding and
innocent nature for her benefit but this
panel marks the moment she starts to
build some sort of bond with the
character
moving on from that opening I think it's
important to point out that this Arc is
unlike any other Dragon Ball Arc that
will come after it it's clear that
Toriyama went into this with a specific
Vision one that was inspired largely by
the Chinese Story Journey to the West
with characters like Goku oolong and
yamsha among others encountering
Fantastical beings clearly inspired by
the aforementioned story and across
these opening 23 chapters Goku and Bulma
travel across the globe in search of
these magical orbs called Dragon Balls
title drop all in an effort so that
Bulma can make a wish for a perfect
boyfriend you heard me right she wants
to wish for a boyfriend oh how the times
have changed in pursuing these orbs they
meet oolong who was this weird
shape-shifting pervert we meet Yamcha
and poor as they attempt to Rob Goku and
KO in the desert as well as a Litany of
bizarre and crazy characters like boss
rabbit an individual in charge of a gang
of rabbit cosplaying thugs that also
possesses the power to turn individuals
link bomber into a carrot this first Arc
is Off the Wall Bonkers bouncing from
Iconic scenes to comedic scenes to
outright strange scenes but what ties
them all together is the strong focus on
Comedy that this first Arc primarily
basks in the original Dragon Ball
particularly this first Saga is very
commonly focused with entire scenarios
sometimes being built around a single
joke and these jokes have layers to them
not layers of any intellectual
complexity definitely not but layers of
loose narrative complexity and I mean
that for instance despite many of you
not having seen this part of the story
you may have seen this particular scene
all right so this one gag highlighting
the innocence of Goku in this crazy
situation has the knock-on effect
whereby it informs and drives the plot
through a secondary gag with roshi later
on convincing him to hand over his
Dragon Ball later again after Bulma
loses the capsules with her clothes and
supplies she has to borrow a dumb outfit
from oolong it's a shallow gag but
funnily enough it informs much of the
humor behind the hijinks that takes
place in the village with boss Rabbit
running the roost this town they wander
into has been terrorized by this gang
that dresses up as rabbits and when the
townsfolks start to give Bulma a wide
berth because of what she's wearing she
assumes the only possible conclusion is
that they're intimidated by her beauty
all of these scenarios the stuff with
Goku roshi oolong and eventually boss
rabbit are all examples of comedic
moments that only work when we know the
characters involved bulmas scaring
people while dressed as a Playboy bunny
is a funny visual on its own but it's
even more funny when you know that this
was the only outfit that oolong had
extra in his car and it's made even
funnier here again when you realize that
Bulma is so egotistical that she
convinced herself that it made perfect
sense that people were treating her this
way because she was so beautiful now is
it stupid and borderline creepy given
bulma's age in the material and the age
of the mangaka drawing it yeah
definitely maybe but it's still made in
light-hearted fun and layered through
character narratively pushing the story
forward people nowadays love to take
Dragon Ball very seriously whether it be
its theme story or messaging and this
story no doubt means a lot to tons and
tons of different people across the
world but at the end of the day this
story particularly this material in the
ark was written as a comedy first and
foremost not to be taken very seriously
at all I mean there's an entire page
with the peel off gang dedicated to
talking about and making meta jokes
concerning toriyama's prior work in Dr
slump zad and also Goku sent boss rabbit
to the Moon using his Noble or power
pole or whatever you want to call it
makes you wonder what happened to him
when
just kiddo
[Music]
YouTube tells me my audience is 94 male
with 80 of you being between the ages of
18 and 34. unfortunately that means most
of you guys are at the age where male
patent ball in this is a scary and very
real threat two out of three of you will
experience it by the time you're 35.
thankfully however this is where keeps
his clinically proven hair loss
treatment comes in to stop hair loss and
improve hair growth if you decide to
join keeps you'll gain access to their
24 7 team of Expert Medical advisors who
review your situation and recommend the
best treatment plan for your personal
needs each plan gives you a full year of
unlimited contact with your medical
provider so you can keep in touch
throughout the treatment should you have
any questions whether it's preventing
hair loss encouraging hair growth or
simply taking better care of your
existing hair keeps has options for
everybody it's extremely convenient and
perfect if you're super lazy like me
you'll get refill reminders and the
treatments are delivered straight to
your door so it's great if you're at all
anxious or extremely busy most keeps
customers notice results within six
months of starting treatment so if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss with keeps head over to
keeps.com not Mark or click the link in
the description to receive 50 off your
first order again that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash not mark
[Music]
all right so before I dive into my
absolute favorite aspect of this first
Arc I think I should rattle off some of
the iconic scenes and honorable mentions
I have also I loved how cute and
innocent both Goku and Chichi's first
encounter was and I love how the way
their dialogue is written accentuates
their rural backgrounds and
sensibilities not only by creating some
endearing character writing but forcing
us as readers to see similarities
between the two of them on a
foundational fundamental level as Goku's
obliviousness clashes with Chichi's
traditional ideal the dynamic is
honestly perfect from a lower standpoint
it also acts as the first place we see
Goku's tail acting as a significant weak
spot in the series moving on the first
Kamehameha in the series is absolutely
top tier these page spreads from Akira
Toriyama absolutely hit different
compared to so many other mangaka both
past and present to me furthermore in
addition to this scene's stunning
visuals we get to see Goku nail the
Kamehameha almost immediately after
seeing roshi use it once this marks the
moment roshi saw Goku as a special
Prospect going as far as to offer him
training once he's ready oh my God is
that foreshadowing I I think it is
alright now time for my favorite part of
the first Arc
while I enjoyed the first Arc story in a
lighthearted passive fashion up until
this point it wasn't until this arc's
climax that Dragon Ball became what I
recognized as Dragon Ball and while it's
still not in its final form just yet
I'll get to that in the next Arc it
still showed signs of heading in that
direction this change in narrative
Direction wasn't a mistake either and
there's some really interesting behind
the scenes info regarding how Toriyama
and his editor at the time Tori Shima
saw this issue that I am totally going
to talk about in like two minutes
narratively however I think this is the
ark's strongest section there's a
wonderful culmination of plot threads
that create a beautiful Martini of
circumstance particularly during this
instance where pilaf has stolen all of
the Dragon Balls they collected and
trapped them in this chamber with the
ceiling exposed to the sky readying them
to be baked onto the hot Morning Sun
once it eventually Rose sitting there
while waiting for death they begin
chatting about the moon's Beauty until
Goku starts talking about his experience
with the moon and in doing so he begins
telling them a story of a monster his
grandpa warned him about that comes out
during a full moon having been exposed
to the otherworldly strength of Goku his
heightened senses and the sudden death
of his grandpa Gohan this is when the
characters sharing the chamber with him
as well as us at home start to
understand what tragic event transpired
that day
[Music]
horribly subtle and effective
particularly for a manga that
prioritizes gags and action Above This
sort of character-rich experience and
it's this sort of dedication to slowly
unveiling the World building it up over
time that gave Dragon Ball this mystical
magic and fun feel during this period as
well as moving forward designing
characters that are exact opposites of
each other and transporting them through
this adventure not with any specific
goal in mind necessarily but to see how
this experience impacts them personally
in the case of Goku we learn all of this
new information about him and in the
case of Bulma she gained some new
friends and maybe more by the way I love
this page where Bulma and yancha both
recognize that they were exactly what
each other were looking for all along
the page layout is great and Visually
communicates what it needs to in a
childish and endearing manner you know
after oolong wishes for panties which is
another great moment and page I guess
however what many of you might not know
is that during this time the ending
portion of the pilaf Saga sails for
Dragon Ball dipped noticeably or
experienced a lull Accord
Dragon Ball's editor that worked
alongside Toriyama and to remedy this
apparently torashima turned to study
fists of the North Star the most popular
manga at the time and after reading it
he identified three areas where Dragon
Ball could improve moving forward number
one the first thing they did was cut
down the number of characters throughout
the first Arc Toriyama had introduced a
large number of new characters like Goku
Bulma oolong Yamcha poor roshi Turtle Ox
King Chichi Mai Shu pilaf as well as the
numerous other villains they encountered
along the way and so when moving into
the next Arc of the story together they
decided to have a much smaller more
focused cast centered around Goku roshi
and the newly introduced Krillin the
second thing they wanted to focus on was
to increase the coolness factor which
also flows naturally into the third
thing they wanted to change they wanted
to break the established Convention of
the series part of the reason sails
declined torashima suspected was due to
the formula that appeared in the first
Arc once the genie was out of the bottle
or in this case dragon fans got the
impression and that they knew what
direction the series would go in and so
the tournament Saga was born ushering in
a new era of manga and in turn
establishing Dragon Ball as a force to
be reckoned with the rise of Dragon Ball
had begun training with roshi to say
that this Arc influenced other popular
series yet to come would be an
understatement after having taken on the
philosophy of less is more from fists of
the north star and a quick trip abroad
to look at some ruins in ancient
architecture Akira Toriyama was primed
to inject Dragon Ball with the same
Vigor passion and action it would become
famous for in the not so distant future
and it all starts with this little boy
asking this old perverted man to train
him like the first Arc enjoy this one
also has a strong focus on the more
lighthearted aspects of the series
particularly through new characters and
their introductions instead of telling
us what sort of people these characters
are clunkily the vehicle of Comedy helps
us understand them more for instance
soon after Goku arrives on the island
and fails to locate a woman for roshi
Krillin makes his grand entrance onto
the scene
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
he comes across as a more self-centered
individual initially thanks to a certain
comedic moment courtesy of Goku's cloud
in addition to that another character we
get to know in this Arc is that of lunch
or launch in the dub she's a character
tailor-made for URI Dragon Ball with her
sneezing offering up tons of comedic
hijinks but my favorite joke from her
more subdued innocent side comes by way
of Roshi's desperate persuasion attempt
to make her wear a specific
uniform after coming out dressed in what
she was given lunch asks if maybe the
packages got mixed up we then hard cut
to the three guys all peddling this same
charade wearing the same uniform and in
response to this roshi humbly requests
that she please don't insult the
traditional uniform of the Kami school
as he lears lechously towards her
flanked by a visibly confused Goku
that's taking all of this a little too
seriously much the same way a strong
emphasis was placed on the differences
between Goku and Bulma early on Krillin
acts in the first half of this Arc as
the foil to Goku with a strong
distinction made between them almost
immediate Italy first they threw his
failure to board the magical Cloud but
also his last and heroic saving of lunch
and most importantly through the
training he received from roshian
speaking of which
[Music]
I loved the training of Krillin and Goku
their Dynamic is Pitch Perfect for what
this Arc is calling for and acts as a
strong first indication of the insecure
antagonistic character type that will
become more and more commonplace around
Goku moving forward bouncing well off of
his innocent and honest Persona Roshi's
introductory challenge the foot race is
a terrific example of why this character
type and why this version of Krillin is
entertaining an effective taking turns
Krillin explodes Off the Mark first
completing the 100 meter dash in a
little over 10 seconds an impressive
effort no matter who you are however
what makes this a great opportunity for
characterization is what Toriyama has
given these characters to say to each
other in response to their respective
efforts with Krillin this gave us a
great indication as to where his ideas
and goals lie basking in the impressive
time he said gloating about it both to
Goku roshi and even internally to
himself whereas with Goku once he sets
an even faster time he doesn't gloat
instead his first instinct is to
genuinely ask if that was fast in the
next challenge when it came to
retrieving The Rock roshi through
Krillin and Goku are first of all faced
with descending a certain Cliff face
however we know from the first chapter
that this is no issue for Goku and
watching as surprised descends over
krillin's face is the first instance of
another trick soon to become commonplace
in the Dragon Ball story this is a
narrative tool called dramatic irony we
know what Goku is capable of but new
characters like Krillin in this instance
don't it is fun and somewhat cathartic
at this point but later this same
technique will be used to effectively
depict Goku as a monstrous threat to the
ignorant adversaries of the future
furthermore this whole challenge is a
brilliantly constructed scene
narratively with more moving Parts than
you might actually anticipate from an
early Dragon Ball story Krillin knowing
full well that there are tons of people
living on this island that they've moved
to for training instead of finding the
rock that roshi threw in a race with
someone he knows he'll lose against
Krillin decides to try to borrow a
marker and find a similar looking Rock
to fake his successful retrieval roshi
does throw the rock back into his face
but it's a good idea that involves
thinking outside of the box Krillin
honestly impressed me here but he's also
demonstrating a character flaw that will
always mean Goku will be better than him
if he doesn't shake this sensibility
despite this admittedly clever idea
however he's forced to search in Earnest
for the rock but to no success once
again Goku finds it however through some
more underhanded and clever use of
strategy he out thinks Goku and
distracts him with a fake rock this
whole interaction challenge was a fun
little exchange that highlights Goku's
weak spots also a weak spot he'll have
for a very very long time in some shape
or form he trusts his opponents too much
but that's enough of these warm-ups it's
time for some serious roshi training
[Music]
one does not strive for victory over an
opponent one strives to avoid defeat by
one's own self in the beginning of this
final set of Trials roshi announces to
the two young boys that in eight short
months they will be participating in the
Tenkaichi Budokai a World Martial Arts
Tournament and what makes this sequence
interesting for me at least isn't
exclusively how powerful these two stand
to become or the amazing techniques they
will learn while training under roshi in
fact they don't really learn any
techniques at all beyond what they
already arrived with instead there's a
strong focus on philosophy through the
intense manual labor education and
effort put in over these months fans of
Dragon Ball super might recognize a
particular quote sitting in a hammock
alongside the first pupils he's taken on
in a very very long time he tells them
to move well study well play well eat
well rest well that is the turtle Master
way there are a number of brilliant
quotes from this training mini Arc but
my favorite is the one I started this
section with one does not strive for
victory over an opponent once dry to
avoid defeat by one's own self it
summarizes simply what I love about this
story and Roshi's teachings particularly
he talks about using the power acquired
through this practice for the betterment
and protection of others to never strive
with the single-minded view of winning
against your opponent but to instead not
fall into the pitfalls such elusive
thinking will lead you down to always
look past that and to always strive to
better yourself regardless of the
immediate goal or outcomes you face it's
a powerful and resilient philosophy that
Toriyama has baked into the foundation
of this franchise and a perfect piece of
serious and useful philosophy amidst the
silliness of this action-adventure comic
foreign
[Music]
this is the first tournament in the
Dragon Ball series however for those of
you that know this series well you'll
know that this isn't by any means the
last not in any stretch of the
imagination the broader Dragon Ball
story these days is somewhat synonymous
with tournament arcs of various shapes
and sizes whether they be these
Tenkaichi budakai more intimate Affairs
like with Baba later on in the story The
Cell games are even to varying degrees
in The Wider Universe Dragon Ball's
roots are very much in these tournament
arcs that help to popularize and it
started all here and it starts with a
bang on the back of that important
philosophy lesson is the two boys's very
first test in the big bad world and the
test isn't necessarily the tournament
itself which honestly was kind of
interesting the significance this
tournament represents is once more
embedded in the philosophy that to truly
be a master of martial arts you need to
always be learning and improving and if
either Goku or Krillin were to win this
tournament and be crowned strongest
under the heavens they might not learn
learned that lesson and given what roshi
has seen them do during their training
he needs to come up with a solution to
this potential problem fast now when you
say tournament Arc a surface level
analysis of that statement might lead
you to believe that this setting only
offers fights and while it does offer
those in abundance it's more than
anything else a simple backdrop that
allows the story and characters to shine
brighter due to the various scenarios it
can readily provide similar to the
setting of a high school tournaments are
a familiar and easy to understand
setting for readers these settings
create natural scenarios for Central or
relevant characters to come into
conflict with each other and in the case
of the Shonen action genre a tournament
Arc is tailor-made for that sort of
story as readers this is our first time
encountering a World tournament in the
universe of Dragon Ball much the same
way this is Krillin and Goku's first
time and these qualifying rounds in the
tournament for the eight main tournament
spots available act also as the bridging
of any Gap there might exist between
Krillin and the audience a character
that was once an antagonist to our hero
Goku is now much closer to the endearing
self-conscious and apprehensive
character we're familiar with today in
addition to him acting early on as the
audience's surrogate in this too being
his first World Tournament asking all
the sort of questions we as readers
would ask he too is confronted by the
group he fled from one that exhibits all
the characteristics he had towards the
beginning of this Arc in other words
we're made aware of the people who made
Krillin the person he was they are slimy
cruel and they are fighting Krillin in
the qualifiers
[Music]
thank you
yeah that felt good goodbye old Krillin
hello bold new world and really these
qualifiers here are all about catharsis
and context it allows us as an audience
the opportunity to take stock of how
capable these boys are after the
grueling and laborious training they
underwent for the better part of a year
against all of these strongest fighters
in the world with little effort Goku and
Krillin qualify along with a returning
short-haired Yamcha for the final eight
next up are the quarterfinals as it
pertains to this tournament's various
heats the quarterfinals are probably the
ones with the greatest emphasis on
Comedy and really for me are the weakest
of the arc no that's not to say that I
didn't have fun reading this section or
that it doesn't have strong moments it
most definitely does like Yamcha vs
Jackie Chan for instance but fights like
bacterium versus Krillin and Goku vs
giren are very clearly there to
primarily dish out some comedic relief
which is fine but I would have liked a
little more drama personally but yeah
Chris's first serious editing as I said
is against an apparently formidable
adversary called bacterium a giant man
whose Edge comes from his refusal to
ever bathe there's some great paneling
by Toriyama here that will become more
commonplace as we press forward too with
the contrast emphasized between the tiny
hero and the giant bully right before
he's defeated with that said the fight
comes to a close thanks to Goku
reminding Krillin that he doesn't have a
nose and therefore can't smell him
[Music]
fatality
[Music]
next up is Yamcha vs Jackie Chun and it
is my favorite of the fights from this
section it's here we're made aware that
roshi under an alias and disguise has
entered himself into the tournament to
prevent the two boys from winning and
losing their motivation for improvement
told from the point of view of Yamcha we
follow him as he's totally overpowered
by the older martial artist in Jackie
Chan there's some great panel work but
it's probably the shortest fight in all
of these main contests
thank you
namu vs ranfern is a strange one as a
reader you'd be forgiven for wondering
why we're dedicating time to this
conflict it doesn't involve any
character we've been introduced to and
so Toriyama offered this up as an
opportunity to not necessarily focus on
namu though he does sort of but to
instead leverage his Noble intentions
that we do learn about him to build up
Roshi's character instead through this
number character we learn how much roshi
may very well be capable of as he uses
his mysterious abilities to read namu's
mind and in addition to that we learn of
the horrible circumstances after
befalling his village waiting on him to
return with water after he wins the
tournament prize money his goal is to
save his village and that motivation
despite ranfen's best effort was enough
to help him claim the victory over her
Goku vs Kiran is the last fight before
the semis and to be honest this was the
fight I liked the least in this section
it's still perfectly fine but there's a
lot of strange goings on like Goku using
Kinton to save himself from falling out
of bounds I mean to me that feels like
cheating I suppose the most significant
thing to come out of this match is that
Goku grew his tail back but even then
Goku doesn't knock you down out of
bounds or anything during quits out of
fear it's very unsatisfying the
semi-finals alright we've got four
remaining contestants vying for the
first place spot Goku Krillin namu and
Jackie Chun three matches remain before
we Crone a winner so let's dive in
Krillin vs Jackie Chun this first match
of the semi-finals is honestly a classic
Dragon Ball fight there's some iconic
Toriyama paneling but trust me you've
seen nothing yet this conflict also has
a brilliant gag which parodies those old
kung fu films you know those moments
where two Warriors Rush past each other
we see effectively nothing happen and
then out of seemingly nowhere one of
them Falls after apparently being
attacked incredibly quick it's a famous
and somewhat cliche trick and Toriyama
decides to deconstruct this concept
until all that's left is otter absurdity
as quillin and roshi I mean Jackie Chan
youth lies the same attack resulting in
Krillin being downed per the request of
the ref they then attempt to explain
everything that happened in
approximately 0.2 seconds of action in
excruciating detail intentionally
slowing the pace of the fight down in
hilarious fashion everything from kicks
punches spitting booger flicking or even
rock paper scissors transpired during
that exchange apparently and it's a
great gag the highlight of this fight
for me anyway has to be when Krillin
surprises Jackie and sends him flying
out of the ring forcing him to use his
secret weapon the Kamehameha to propel
himself back into the arena it's awesome
after that effort Krillin didn't have
much left and in the end Jackie Chan
proved to be too much for the young
Warrior
Chun advances to the finals
this is namu's semi-final bout was
interesting for me for one main reason
it acted as a clear and effective way to
show what sort of Powerhouse Goku really
is taking techniques he'd just seen
moments prior and utilizing them in
battle with namu made it look as though
Goku was barely trying aside from
Krillin and roshi namu would have been
the strongest man to participate within
this tournament and to see Goku's
steamroll through him like this created
an aura around his character I wasn't at
all expecting from this story going into
what should be the biggest moment in his
life needless to say Goku wins he
advances to the finals against Jackie
Chun in dominating fashion the finals
this is and remains one of the best
fights the series has ever produced and
it's a crime that most people that have
seen Dragon Ball Z don't even know that
this fight exists contained within this
one fight are what will eventually
become Staples of the franchise that to
this day are still being used there's an
interesting interview with toriyama's
editor Tori Shima that I think brings to
life the reason why a tournament setting
was ultimately chosen to act as the
backdrop for the climax to their
sophomore outing in this manga nothing
from fists of the North Star pointed
towards a tournament Arc necessarily so
what was it well it was a kiratoriyama's
art style according to torashima tetsu
Ohara the artist behind fists of the
North Star was particularly great at
illustrating still or static images and
so torashima wondered if Hara had to
keep this in mind when drawing his manga
playing to his strengths resulting in
kinshira poking holes through his
opponents and making them stagger to the
right there's not a lot of movement but
it was so cool according to torashima
and so once he realized this he thought
angled the coming Arc according to Akira
toriyama's greatest illustrative Talent
his ability to depict three-dimensional
movement toriyama's level of spatial
awareness when it comes to these fights
was what drew me as a reader and a fan
into these stories in the first place
and largely what set the series apart
from other actions Children of the time
keeping these aspects of Akira
toriyama's talents in mind they needed a
place to easily demonstrate themselves
and what better place to show how
powerful and competent Goku became than
on a flat three-dimensional stage at the
Tenkaichi Budokai on this stage Akira
Toriyama was free to make full use of
the space whether it be through jumping
flying lunging spinning or whatever his
brain could conjure and this fight
between roshi and Goku set the standard
for what many other manga from that
point onward would try to emulate an
aspect of this fight that I think is
easily overlooked is how so much of it
is taken from Roshi's point of view from
the internal dialogue to the point of
view and narrative Direction The
Narrative is less saying can Goku pull
out the victory here but more so can
roshi achieve what is best for Goku in
defeating him in this contest on top of
that remaining true to the initial
mission statement of the turtle school
and its philosophy it really helps to
build up and establish Goku as there's a
mountain of an adversary early on in the
boat which in turn helps to build
tension in the fight towards its climax
forcing us to watch on as an audience
conflicted as roshi Cycles through and
Dives deep into his big bag of tricks
with Goku finding every answer to the
techniques the old Herman had acquired
over a very very long career in mere
seconds it's an astounding fight and
it's not done yet
due to the fight's length and
subsequently Roshi's inability to put
Goku away early Knight Falls over the
arena and the moon comes out forcing
roshi to contend with the impossibly
difficult task of great ape Goku now
destroying the tournament grounds and
contend with him he most certainly does
in fittingly ridiculous Dragon Ball
fashion might I add by using almost all
of his energy to blow up the moon rip
boss rabbit I guess ultimately this
leaves both roshi and Goku almost
completely drained of energy with one
good attack left in each competitor and
the means with which this fight ends is
still to this day genius in my mind it's
so simple it meant that there was a
winner declared but with no one person
having lost any standing with us as an
audience ever the cunning strategist at
the last moment roshi notices an
advantage he has over Goku one that no
matter what the young boy couldn't
possibly overcome his lack of height and
reach for the very last time in this
boat they Dash and move to attack each
other and this time both fall after
their respective blows land but
ultimately roshi dealt the most damage
thanks to Goku's lack of reach leading
to a graze instead of a solid connection
on the turtle hermit this fight was a
brilliant use of every single attribute
that makes Akira toriyama's stories and
battles impressive and revisiting it for
me was a tremendous treat having not
looked at it in close to 10 years
returning to it with fresh eyes I am
happy to say that not only is it as good
as I remember but it's better the focus
this Arc places on the character of
roshi is stupendous from his comedic
value to his competency as a martial
artist to his generosity as a human
being this Arc was a true tour de force
proclaiming to the world that Dragon
Ball has arrived and let me tell you it
was only just getting started
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is gonna be a big one guys so let's
not delay I'm toy not Mark and this is
my review of Akira toriyama's underrated
and undefeated Dragon Ball
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
my biggest nitpick concerning the modern
Dragon Ball super anime for those of you
that haven't seen that review series I
made over a year ago has to be its
sudden and abrupt cold openings to new
arcs when the Battle of God's Ark ends
it ends and then a completely new story
disconnected from the prime material
would begin a new and the same is true
for Universe 6 and Goku black and so
forth and all of these feel like
self-contained stories not necessarily
connected in any meaningful way
narratively to the prior this doesn't
bother everyone but to me it misses a
mark the original Dragon Ball and Z
would always hit for instance off the
back of the 21st Tenkaichi Budokai that
I covered last week there's some nice
lightheaded humor with Goku pretty much
eating all the prize money's worth of
food courtesy of roshi himself but what
I like most about this scene was its
immediate redirection of her attention
towards a new goal a goal that will
inform the direction for the next Arc
the retrieval of Grandpa Gohan's
four-star Dragon Ball the Red Ribbon
Army Saga as has been the case since the
beginning of this story thus far whom
moving forward there will continue to be
a pervasive and strong comedic energy
throughout the upcoming material however
what I want to draw your attention to
before we get into the story proper is
as it progresses I'd like for you guys
to pay attention to the slowly
escalating sense of drama and Stakes I
ask this not because there will
necessarily be noticeable stakes in this
video I mean there very well might be
Lord knows I'm not going to spoil you
but this escalation in mood stakes and
drama will undoubtedly manifest in some
impressive and game-changing ways later
and so as we race forward into this
Brave New World in search of Goku's Four
Star Dragon Ball I think you should keep
in mind where we started in the last
video and appreciate the growth as it
becomes more and more distinct slowly
becoming the story we're familiar with
in Z so Goku slung across the sky when
he's suddenly shot down by a missile
launcher I repeat Goku and kinderun are
both blown out of the sky by a missile
launcher everyone this is the first
Contact Goku makes with the antagonists
of this Arc through one Colonel silver
he has a annoyingly and single-handedly
created an enemy that will become more
powerful than he or anyone else in this
world could possibly imagine in this
story Goku challenges the most powerful
evil organization in the world the Red
Ribbon Army
[Music]
also in search of the Dragon Balls
the driving forces of this narrative
something I thought was great was how
Goku's friendship with Bulma was the
reason he's able to hone in on these
Dragon Balls much faster and more
effectively than the Red Ribbon Army can
organically it creates the necessary
tension to bring them into contact and
without words communicates why they are
in Conflict It's a Wonderful mechanism
in this regard that's quite believable
muscle Tower while this red ribbon Army
ARC is the longest of any we've covered
thus far dealing with three commanding
officers increasing in importance as we
go through the three acts of the story
in this opening act we're kicking things
off with General white and his Fortress
shrouded in treacherous icy Tundra this
is a terrific example again of Akira
toriyama's desire to create an
interesting but easy to understand place
to take full advantage of his audience's
anticipation and his ability to draw
well in 3D space if his audience can
understand the space in a
three-dimensional sense then he can do
much more with the action
oh
[Music]
when I first went through this years ago
something I didn't fully appreciate was
how nice it was that we got some time to
spend with Goku one-on-one as a
character alone I was honestly pretty
surprised it took so long for something
like this to happen oh and by the way
this opening Arc which effectively acts
as an empowerment to the audience and
Goku as they cut through the red ribbon
Army like butter watching as he
obliterates his way through General
White's defenses floor after floor is
again very fun but this section is also
reinforcing Goku's character as someone
that will want to do the right thing for
those that did right by him protecting
the defenseless Village against the Red
Ribbon Army who are looking to get the
dragon ball in the area and radar into
their possession in other words Goku's
protecting those that need his
protection pocketing back to the last
arcs philosophy and I loved it
furthermore the framing of these
encounters is sort of gamified or fun
for lack of a better term the goal is to
get to the top of the tower reprimand
General white and save the town's mayor
from capture with every floor
introducing more and more intense
conflicts going from grunts on the
ground floor to the conflict with full
metal jacket on the word the first
robotic foe Goku has faced in the series
definitely a trend of things to come
this fight against Full Metal Jacket is
actually sort of suspenseful mostly
because it provides a strong contrast
with the initial floors and
confrontations between Goku and the
earlier portion of the Red Ribbon army
with Colonel silver not putting up much
of a fight at all with this fight
totally taking Goku and his new
extensive Powers totally by surprise as
the mechanical monstrosity relentlessly
pushes Goku more than any fight he's
encountered since roshi
okay
the fourth floor fight against sergeant
major purple the ninja is very comedy
focused the purple fight consists of at
first a game of hide and seek with Goku
falling his concealment strategies at
every conceivable turn in increasingly
ridiculous fashion overall compared to
the prior battle this encounter acts as
another opportunity for Goku to flex how
much more powerful he is than a cocky
opponent it's totally completely
different to the Full Metal Jacket fight
leaning perhaps more than any other
fight into the more comedic gag format
and I say that while also being fully
aware that earlier Goku sent a humanoid
gangster rabbit to the moon on an
extendable Pole
as soon as Android 8 shows his face he
immediately contrasted himself with full
metal jacket and I fell in love with his
character for that he's so ominous and
domineering physically but totally
harmless personally which is in and of
itself another nice contrast to oppose
Goku small but impossibly strong Persona
only on this second read through am I
noticing all of these contrast Toriyama
has implemented here I also love the
role that Android 8 plays in helping
Goku overcome this ninja man in addition
to helping Goku navigate The Mazes that
comprise the upper levels of muscle
Tower I like it because it ultimately
means that Goku manages to escape this
Tower and reach where he wants to go
because of him being a decent person
deep down and for no other reason really
and despite the situation with General
white coming to a close in relatively
quick fashion Goku employs some terrific
and clever strategy against the
General's jiggly contingency plan
utilizing information he gleaned from a
young girl earlier towards the beginning
of the arc demonstrating applied
knowledge way to go Goku but again
because this is a very long Arc
sprawling across 41 chapters Akira
Toriyama decided to break it up into
three easily identifiable portions but
linked them wonderfully and so with the
muscle Tower portion now after coming to
a close we get our next goal almost
immediately off the back of the last
segment you see during the assault in
the tower Goku broke the dragon radar an
understandable unbelievable consequence
that will drag him back into contact
with the weird and wonderful girl who
started this series with him Bulma
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll only touch on this briefly because
it's only a minor part of the story but
Goku arriving in West City in search of
Bulma is handled to absolute perfection
knowing Goku's origin and seeing where
he is now in a bustling Metropolis it
stands to reason that the very first
time he enters a big city like this it'd
be a fish out of water type scenario and
for some reason on my first read-through
I never anticipated this running around
to random people asking them where Bulma
is was a subtle but brilliant insight
into what Goku's expectations and
experiences up until now have been with
him going as far as to remark huh you
live in the same town but you don't know
who she is I love dialogue like that it
really gives us great insight into the
characters sensibilities and
expectations his search for Bulma is
probably the funniest and most endearing
chapter in the story that I've read thus
far it's full of innocent hijinks with
Goku taking Center Stage trying his best
to understand the social customs of the
area going as far as winning money in
street fights because he was led to
believe money equals someone telling him
where boom Maze and when he learns that
cops can help him the person he asks to
find a cop gets all that money that he
won it's brilliant it's light it's over
next general blue Saga I swear to God
blue during the pursuit of the next
Dragon Ball I loved bulma's inclusion
and I thought it was Top Notch on top of
her being in essence a terrific plot
device that can provide Goku with any
help he might need she's also a great
character full of Personality this okay
might seem like a random side note but
one aspect of GT that I didn't like much
was how they used or should I say didn't
use the character of pen introduced in
the opening episode with a lot of
promise I quickly found myself invested
in her budding story and gravitated
towards the character but it never
amounted to anything she always get in
the way needed saving and contributed
little if anything other than
complaining or motivating Goku through
capture and while Bulma still needs help
from Goku Goku wouldn't have ever found
his way to this Dragon Ball beneath the
ocean alone and that's ignoring the
dragon radar she gave him in the first
place Goku quite literally be lost
without her in this instance she more
than pulls her weight in the greater
story or at least she would if she
didn't accidentally take her dad's
capsules instead
and so they reach out to borrow Roshi's
submarine thing and it's here I noticed
the degree to just how empowering this
Arc is during this material Goku is very
seldom if ever on the back foot
dominating every encounter with the red
ribbon Army's increasingly competent
officials that each without fail commit
the cardinal sin of underestimating her
little hero one scene in particular that
stands out to me as specifically
cathartic in this regard is the
confrontation roshi and launch
experience on the island with the red
ribbon Army themselves the fashion with
which launch and specifically roshi
disarmed the situation and clobber every
single soldier was amazing to read
through further adding value to my
Dragon Ball experience I mean if you're
from an English-speaking country odds
are your first introduction to the
series was through Dragon Ball Z and in
that story roshi plays such a minuscule
role you'd be forgiven for thinking he
wasn't anything special at any point in
time but through these early acts
revisiting them helps to reinforce the
type of powerful and competent character
he actually is what makes this middle
portion of the story so fun at least for
me is how bamboozled and perplexed the
Red Ribbon Army under General blue and
red R they are constantly Blown Away by
Goku's speed moving from one location to
another his ability to locate Dragon
Balls immediately which they lack the
tech to do and of course his
otherworldly strength and fighting
prowess and at the moment General blue
and his forces are in pursuit of Goku
Bulma and Krillin as they Venture down
using Roshi's Sub in an underwater cave
in search of the four-star ball Now
cards on the table here I think of the
three sections I'll be discussing of the
Red Ribbon Army ARC this General blue
Saga is perhaps the least interesting I
think in large part because the second
act is in large part difficult to make
is interesting in a story any story with
it primarily serving the purpose of
building up to the events I am super
excited to discuss later on concerning
the third act with that said however
there are still a lot of aspects to this
act particularly from a human
perspective that I really appreciated
General blue is easily the Highlight in
terms of characters presented from the
Red Ribbon Army side effects perhaps
throughout the entire Arc itself his
ruthless pursuit of her Heroes his Mercy
socialist and scary disregard for human
life contrasting beautifully with his
otherwise clean-cut Persona carrying
with it a Sprinkle of Camp humor he's a
bizarre and capable leader and fighter
that places Our Heroes in trouble on
more than one occasion
speaking of which
[Music]
earlier I mentioned that virtually every
advancement the Red Ribbon Army made on
our heroes resulted in their ultimate
downfall thus empowering Our Heroes
beyond what they already were in our
minds as readers or viewers well that
was until General blue finally started
to roll up his sleeves or take off his
shirt whatever you choose and what I
enjoyed about his clash with Krillin
wasn't what I saw but instead what I
didn't see our last checking in with
Krillin was during the semi-finals of
the 21st Tenkaichi Budokai wherein he
demonstrated his martial arts ability
against the eventual winner of the
tournament in Jackie Chan having
narrowly lost that bout against the
eventual winner Krillin was seen at
least to me as close to Goku's level of
strength and thus this was still his
standing alongside the current cast
going into the confrontation with
General blue so keeping in mind that the
Red Ribbon Army had effectively been the
punching bag of the heroes up until now
and that Krillin is seen as a powerful
fighter akin to Goku you'll maybe get a
taste of what sort of Shaka reader would
have had in Japan during the time that
they turned the page to see this we
don't see this fight it's simply cuts
from before the fight to after it
creating a great contrast visually but
as I drew attention to earlier
contrasted powerfully with how we
thought things would go too boastful
prideful flamboyant and downright
ruthless General blue comes out of this
encounter virtually unscathed and with
him mere seconds away from crushing a
paralyzed Krillin skull with a boulder
the consequences of this meeting really
start to set in and I love it when
Toriyama leverages that aspect of comedy
or the gag comic format to create sudden
and abrupt moments of desperation for
his readers and I do so because when a
character is moments from a gruesome
death it creates the perfect opportunity
for A Moment Like This
[Music]
this is the first Rudy dramatic say if
Goku has made that I've recognized
before this in the first Arc any save he
would otherwise make would be
accompanied with significant comedic
references visuals or some combination
of the two however this save is framed
as being entirely dramatic it's subtle
but the development of that more serious
tone ever present in Z is slowly seeping
through the pages gradually even as
early as here the fight itself is
perfectly fine but nothing particularly
interesting outside of that specific
tunnel shift I mentioned effectively the
Fight Continues as many Dragon Ball
fights do in the early chapters with
some nice paneling and gag humor to
undercut the entire Affair Goku
overcomes blue he puts a rat in his
mouth and they eat themselves back to
the surface some more hijings takes
place with launch in general blue and
Roshi's Island that is way more funny
than it has any right to be and then
Goku starts making his way to a familiar
setting for some
as will become something of a tradition
with toriyama's work he likes to Cameo
old characters and not from the same
property but from entirely different
series now I realize I'm speaking to a
minority when I say this but similar to
Jacko the galactic patrolman a manga
written after Dragon Ball ended by Akira
Toriyama himself he decided to make it
known that the story shares the same
world as Dragon Ball did and similarly
to that the final chapters of the
general blue are Goku and the titular
General sort of stumble into the
peculiar Penguin Village fans of his
previous doctor slot material will love
this segment of the story as it goes out
of its way to bring the energy of the
property to the Forefront perhaps
however at the expense of the newly
established Dragon Ball tone though
Diego
it's a nice callback section with its
own Independent high points but I'd be
lying if I thought it wouldn't have been
served better by sticking to its own
property where Jocko's manga benefited I
thought from linking itself to the
greater Tory verse I don't think this
Arc got any more from this particular
interaction in Penguin Village with that
said while it was overly light-hearted
those of you that keep tabs on story
tone might anticipate a tonal shift soon
for when something good happens in a
story normally around the next corner is
something likely not too friendly
Commander red Saga this is the final Act
of the Red Ribbon Army ARC and while I
did enjoy the prior portions this
upcoming final part is my absolute
favorite and the section I've been
itching to talk about all video long I
love the setting I love the expanded
lore it offers and above all else I love
it for one reason specifically
now moving at speed towards another
group of red ribbon army soldiers led by
Colonel yellow we pick up with oopa and
his father these character designs
clearly take inspiration from Native
Americans in North America and they're
pretty cool particularly the father
character he's not overly complicated
but he's courageous righteous and Noble
and he's guarding an area called The
Corn Sanctuary from the incoming Red
Ribbon Army when suddenly
[Music]
having just saved this young boy Goku
finally is reunited with his Grandpa's
four-star Dragon Ball it's a great
moment to finally see this young man
reunited with his prized possession and
all by coming to the rescue of this
group it's a really nice virtuous moment
that yields what he's been searching for
all of this time but just as they're
celebrating a certain assassin is hired
by the Red Ribbon Army to help recover
what they've lost
[Music]
Cow Pie touted as the greatest assassin
for hire in the world is in addition to
the impressive in Universe Accolade one
of the most underrated villains in the
entire Dragon Ball Universe there are a
ton of genuinely impressive villains
later that take the spotlight in the
global Zeitgeist but unlike many of them
this man genuinely would have scared me
as a child in a story with such a large
focus on Joy adventure and comedy for
this no-nonsense cold-blooded killer to
now act as the main antagonist for this
section was a shock to my system you
feel the tone shift violently as soon as
he takes control of the narrative
introduced to us primarily through his
first task of killing General blue for
his past failures keep also in mind the
fact that blue has been perhaps the
single best challenge to Goku behind
roshi and the fashion with which Tau
disposes of blue is as unorthodox as it
is
foreign
yeah this is someone that wastes no time
in killing his opponent and to add to
his intimidation Factor he performs
physical Feats never before seen in the
series like for example he's informed
four area to transport him to Corn
Sanctuary so that he can deal with Goku
right there and then however he declines
rips a pillar from the wall throws it
into the air and rides it over the
horizon studying that he'll be back
shortly with everything they requested
in tow I'd argue that this scene while
silly ought to be I think as iconic as
frieza's floating chair thing what a
visual and what a guy
Goku vs Tau paipai every single molecule
of this fight drives home one specific
message tau is impossibly powerful fast
and deadly Landing thunderously before
Goku and his friends the pillar crashes
to the ground and in mere moments oopa's
father is mercilessly killed there's no
time to even catch her breath or
register the emotions necessary to
understand the horror and tragedy for
Oppa because Tau like a monster turning
his attention to Goku unleashes a
massive strike toward him this is the
first high drama encounter and fight
that there's been in the series there
are no jokes here there's no levity and
there's no ostentatious flaunting of
techniques or poses this is business and
in a few strikes while easily absorbing
Goku's absolute best fires the kill shot
towards Goku this fight felt like a
runaway train that out of nowhere ended
in an instant and I mean that in the
best possible way and as Goku lies there
motionless I couldn't help but think
about how this moment might feel in
retrospect one bit particular element of
Dragon Ball that I absolutely adored was
how routinely our main character Goku
would ultimately be defeated in combat
particularly during the early material
it made for much more interesting fights
bolstered also by the scope of the main
cast dragon balls are still very much a
struggle to acquire without the aid of
Goku and at this point he's being
defeated both by roshi acting as Jackie
Chan and now mercenary Tau this is a
character that while powerful gifted and
with his intentions honest still comes
up against mountains he has to Humble
himself before and in the face of these
encounters we see what Goku is truly
made of speaking from experience I think
one stands to learn a lot about someone
or in this case a character when they
face devastating defeat winning does
offer plenty of opportunity for
personality identifiers but few
instances in our lives I think highlight
what we're made of better than a loss
and the more devastating the better Goku
very nearly died in horrific death by
the Lightning Fast hands of this
psychopath and how did he survive
thanks
rooting around for the reason behind the
survival he finds that the four-star
ball blocked the final shot from Tao
citing that his grandpa saved him it's a
touching and beautiful sentiment
particularly when you consider that Goku
was given that Dragon Ball in the first
place for being a good person but the
means with which he survived while
thematically and symbolically gorgeous
at the end of the day only further
served to highlight just how impossibly
lucky Goku was in this exchange for many
this would be enough to push one into
reconsidering their life's Direction
surrounded by a terrified child and the
corpse of his father Goku is faced with
this scary close call while holding what
he came on this dangerous adventure for
the four-star ball he secured his goal
and could very easily call it a day here
but to Goku none of this matters in fact
I wouldn't even be surprised if none of
this even crossed his mind as a
possibility for the moment he assessed
the situation Goku realizes that there's
only one thing he can do and he jumps to
it
foreign
for those of you that don't know this is
significant because as Legend has it in
this chapter if one can climb this Tower
they will be trained by a master capable
of vastly improving their ability and
strength and according to those Goku
spoke to no one in recent memory has
claimed it scary for any sane human
being sure but Goku continues to climb
fearlessly and as Goku begins scaling
this ridiculous structure we're greeted
by some more gorgeous Toriyama paneling
showing our hero tirelessly scaled this
thought to be near impossible structure
to climb forcing us as readers to notice
that not only is Goku doing this because
he wants to resurrect oopa's father but
he's also doing this in the way that
he's supposed to without the help of
kintu going as far as to sleep on the
side of the tower waking up with little
strength left as the sun rises about to
reach his limit he sees something
one aspect of this reread through the
series that I've noticed has been all of
the elements to Dragon Ball Z that I
liked being present and clearly inspired
from choices made during this material
to some extent Jackie Chan vs Goku's
beam struggle is clearly a Trope that
will be used for years to come I've
mentioned numerous narrative Trends with
Goku and his allies that will become
more consistent as time moves forward
and I'm now noticing it more
consistently with Karen's Sanctuary it's
very clearly operating under the same
narrative principle that snake way and
King Kai enjoyed think about it a Hermit
martial arts master living at the end of
a perilous Journey our hero most Brave
in order to achieve the strength
possible to defeat evil and protect
others the description works perfectly
for both kinkai and korin so when you
look at this thinking about corn as a
prototype King Kai character what was
Goku's experience like with him on the
tower well it actually is a little less
straightforward than kinkai's unlike him
coren's teachings are a little more
sneaky a misdirect if you will tasking
Goku immediately with drinking some
special water atop a pedestal it very
much becomes a high-stakes game of keep
away as Goku for three days chases the
little cat man all over the tower in an
effort to get his hands on this special
water and while this encounter was brief
it illuminated for me something
wonderful about Goku's character yet
again apart from the physical space
being kept between Goku and corn himself
he additionally puts Goku to the test in
other ways the first is a bit more
direct than the others however he throws
the Dragon Ball off the edge forcing
Goku to have to run down and back up but
what really impressed me the most about
Goku in this scene was his mental honor
and strength most obviously there is a
small interaction during one of the
nights where Goku contemplates and puts
himself into the position to take the
water while corn sleeps however despite
this opportunity that's presenting
itself just like his refusal to use
kintabun he decides to not take that
chance but what Goku did didn't know was
that Corin was conscious the entire time
and acknowledges in his mind his honor
being greater than that of his master
roshi who also was there opting to
achieve the victory here the right way
and this moment is made all the more
significant as twice before it Goku is
made aware of just how daunting this
task is he's told first at the ground
that he's unlikely to reach the top and
once he's there he's told that roshi
took three years to achieve the same
feat the honesty and confidence one must
have in their own ability to choose not
to take the easy option by stealing it
while he sleeps says so much more about
the character than any Punch Kick or
beam ever could this is why Goku is
where he is today
what gives this particular training its
own flavor I think is its dedication to
the mysterious Master type format unlike
King Kai who was very direct in his
approach the war that korin was
protecting actually has no magical
properties in fact outside of the one
sense of being corn gave Goku the only
reason Goku managed to get stronger in
any way was due to the extensive Chase
he gave to to corn and his rescaling of
the tower it's very Karate Kid with corn
being Mr Miyagi through this Goku
manages to multiply his power according
to Corin and so now it's time to test
what this new power looks like in combat
and arriving in appropriately dramatic
fashion to make the save on oopa Goku
touches down on the battlefield and if
you thought the first match with Tao was
dominant this one is 10 times worse Tau
barely lands a single attack on Goku and
what he does for the most part it's only
because Goku allows him to what I like
about this fight also is the means with
which Tau secures his demise having
spent the last while being faced with
the sort of honorable character Goku is
when faced with tremendous pressure tau
is exposed as the slimy cowardly cheat
he is once he starts to feel any level
of pressure breaking out extra weapons
to even the odds for him ending with him
throwing a grenade at Goku which he
easily kicks back into his face for me
the Corin Tower until Popeye stuff was
by far the most interesting and
entertaining in this Arc what remains in
it however is effectively a future
chapters of Goku feeling like a God as
he blasts punches and kicks his way
through the remaining forces of the most
evil organization on Earth the most
interesting aspect of these final
moments in the red ribbon Army HQ comes
by way of Commander Red's Mutiny at the
hands of his number two funnily enough
this whole betrayal comes about because
that red character didn't want to use
the balls for world domination but
instead to increase his height which
funnily enough helped me notice yet
another parallel perhaps between this
and modern Dragon Ball in that being
effectively the same sort of wish Frieza
wanted to make in the Broly film but at
the end of the day when offered a
partnership by the new head of the Red
Ribbon Army Goku without hesitation said
no after all he's been through this
massive Arc he's still the same innocent
and honest boy that lived in that small
Hut in the forest of Mount palzu I love
the Tao paipai stuff and I very much
enjoyed the slow shift to more serious
character running towards the end of the
story and while I've loved the journey
up until this point from now on we're
moving on to some of the most serious
and best written material in the manga
[Music]
[Applause]
fortune teller Baba the Red Ribbon Army
ARC while very action and suspense
focused I thought lacked emotional
resonance in the first and second arcs I
covered in this review series I
mentioned how my favorite aspects of
both were what they brought to the table
in an emotional capacity Goku sharing
his memories of his grandpa in pilaf's
Castle informing us of his tragic
circumstances and in the 21st Tenkaichi
Budokai Roshi's moving of Heaven and
Earth in an effort to try and instill
the right teachings in his pupils these
are all brilliantly subversive ideas
that in addition to the comedy in action
helped to elevate all of the material
being told far beyond what would have
otherwise been achieved without it
Dragon Ball is very much a story of
action and comedy but without certain
measured and appropriate levels of drama
almost all of the action loses its sense
of weight tell pipei's encounter with
Goku was powerful because it was
entirely driven by drama lupa's father
had been murdered and so Goku had to try
to improve prove enough such that the
next time he fought Tau he would be able
to prevent him from doing more damage to
more people and driven by that emotional
resonance Goku rematches Tau to great
success however as you may have noticed
last week I decided to quickly scan over
Goku's attack on the Red Ribbon army
base and I did so because that section
was simply just action and comedy there
was virtually no drama involved which I
think is a crying shame Goku just
defeats the Red Ribbon Army plowing
through their ranks with hardly any
resistance and I decided to end it there
because it was the end of the titular
red Ribbit Army for which the ark is
known for Well for now but what if I
told you that wasn't the actual ending
of the arc one of the best aspects to
the format Dragon Ball employs is that
of use in comedy and action as a vehicle
4 telling stories to have an emotional
core and while the main action and
comedic climaxes have reached their
conclusions through the dismantling of
the Red Ribbon Army themselves there
still exists the emotional climate to
this Arc while many might consider this
part separate from the prior Red Ribbon
Army material this Arc still very much
is intrinsically connected to the prior
having begun with a less compelling
desire from Goku to reunite himself with
his grandpa Gohan's Dragon Ball
eventually he amended that desire in
lieu of the circumstances that befell
UPA and his now late father pushing
forth with gusto towards fortune teller
Baba's dwelling in search of an answer
for the final Dragon Ball's location
this portion of the story reminds us
that while the ark was named after the
Red Ribbon Army due to its pervasive
pushback throughout the material this
story is still ongoing and at its core
it's yet to be resolved so let's get to
the core essentially the long and short
of this particular portion of the story
concerns the retrieval of The Last
Dragon Ball where is it the gang doesn't
know it's unable to be located using the
dragon radar for some reason and so they
go to fortune teller Baba's dwelling in
the hopes that she can locate the ball
using her powers this is our first time
meeting this character her appearance is
fun and quirky and I just love the
design at first this seems like a great
solution to their problems however when
the gang arrived to find out that they
have to fight and defeat five Champions
chosen by Baba to get this privilege the
story once again turns into a tournament
of sorts fans of Dragon Ball super will
recognize this knockout style tournament
format as it was used during the
universe 6 tournament against Alexa
Frost and hit unlike that tournament and
those fights from Super however these
are distinctly early Dragon Ball in both
tone and execution for the most part
I'll show you what I mean first up
Krillin vs Count Dracula Krillin opts to
hop in to kick things off with this
challenge in the name of the hero team
first against none other than Count
Dracula almost all of Baba's Champions
follow this monster movie type theme and
the fight with Krillin has some terrific
gag humor that actually got some laughs
out of me but through and through
there's not much to this fight Beyond
some quick laughs and the establishment
of the tournament rules Krillin loses
which means Dracula stays on and up next
poor and oopa this fight is even shorter
though I will say its execution is cute
while also making some nice use of some
lesser utilized characters poor finally
gets to do something so that's cool and
oopa the person that's dictating the
story's conclusion also finds himself
contributing to the ending so that's
nice and I thought their involvement was
clever also with poor making full use of
his shape-shifting abilities Dracula is
eliminated and to make room for Yamcha
war and oopa step down next up Yamcha
versus The Invisible men this fight is a
really weird one and boy is it a time so
Yamcha someone that's already struggling
with relevancy in the story finds
himself struggling against Baba's
Invisible Man the only significant
instance from this fight is the
notorious bulma's boob panel
it's a gag that drags Bowman roshi into
the scene and through the group's
combined efforts krillin's idea lands a
large amount of Roshi's blood over the
Invisible Man resulting in Yamcha then
seeing him and taking the victory it's
one of the most bizarre scenes and now
we're switching the battle stage Yamcha
proceeds to the next round his next
opponent The Mummy Yamcha versus The
Mummy Baba's third Champion is perhaps
the first major challenge to this group
and therefore this is effectively where
the tournament actually starts
everything leading up to this was
Preamble or comedic relief and while
comedy remains prevalent from here on
what with the battle stage literally
being two giant Stone demons sitting on
toilets while tonguing each other the
rules to this one are simple you fall
off the platform you die from falling
into the acid beneath and if you quit
you lose it's that's it apparently and
in this fight with the mummy Yamcha is
quickly overwhelmed making room for our
main man G that dons the orange ghee
Goku Goku vs The Mummy there's some
really nice panel work here and terrific
use of the mummy's powers to prevent him
from falling off the stage but in the
end this fight only serves to show one
thing how incredible Goku is and how
blown away those in his friend group are
at his overwhelming strength in the end
Goku was too much he advances Baba's
next Champion is
the devil while brief much like the
prior confrontation with the mummy
Goku's fight with the Devil is
interesting for two specific reasons I
think firstly this devil individual as
roshi points out to us is normally
Baba's fifth Champion which means
there's someone special waiting in the
wings to come out as her fifth secret
Champion once Goku disposes of the
Devilman it's a nice teaser for later
and at that point in the story I was
still done the wiser as to who that
surprise fighter might be another aspect
that I thought was quite cool also kind
of funny was that of the devil man's
secret weapon this beam that he employs
enlarges the impurities or evil in one's
Soul until they explode or die but
what's cool about this is is that it
does nothing to Goku he has no evil in
him and thus the beam did absolutely
nothing what I found funny however about
this section was that of Baba's reaction
she seems to show tremendous concern for
Goku's life and thought the devil was
going too far and her feeling that way
would be fine if not for the fact that
the ring is designed to have people fall
off to their death if you don't want the
fighters to die then don't make the
floor acid baba but yeah as I alluded
towards the beginning of this video this
Arc surrounding fortune teller Baba and
her Champions is very much the emotional
climax to this Arc as well as the
culmination of the through line to this
entire story across its narrative Goku
has traveled far and wide in search of
what began as loose reasons born out of
sentimentality in retrieving his
Grandpa's Treasure Dragon Ball and has
now evolved into a virtuous quest to
revive a friend's father and having now
fallen dismantled Baba's devil her
former number one Champion we sit and
wait for for a surprise fifth Champion
to make themselves known to both us the
readers and Goku
h
this is one of my favorite Encounters in
all of the Dragon Ball story including z
if there's one thing I would have liked
the series to lean more into later in
its stories it would have been a more
relationship focused story from the very
beginning of the Dragon Ball series
we've been made aware of the Life Goku
once had and through this long journey
we've grown to appreciate and understand
the little monkey child and the bizarre
habits he possessed he had known but
over time grew strong and made loads of
wonderful new friends and one could
argue because of the lessons his grandpa
Gohan instilled in him and having
started off this Arc In Search of an
item that represents his grandpa in the
end despite having to give up that for
someone else he still got what he wanted
in this scene Goku versus his deceased
grandpa Gohan is perfect from the subtle
hints leading up to the reveal utilizing
Goku's sense of smell to Gohan reminding
Goku to Bow all the way to the clever
use of his knowledge concerning Goku's
weak points and while the the fight is
something in and of itself to Marvel
after I think what I love most about
this comes in the way of that subtle
breadcrumb hint trail that leads to the
Outburst of emotion from Goku at its
climax he's most definitely not the
sentimental sword nor is he the kind to
lament over or think nostalgically about
the past
but in this moment it's really brought
to the Forefront of the story that he's
a little kid and he missed his grandpa
during a large portion of his life all
he had in the world was him it's
beautiful and I don't think I was the
only one who thought so either I mean
with Dragon Ball super paying homage to
this very moment in Goku while he was
waiting for frieza's arrival during the
tournament of power lead up he relives
the fight in his mind with his late
Grandpa by going through the techniques
and poses used during the encounter it's
a moment that meant a lot to him and
when Gohan took that mask off the joy in
Goku as he bursts out crying and smiling
with a big hug is enough to warm the
coldest of hearts out there he set out
to find an important connection to his
friend Paul through the four star ball
he gave up on that goal for the benefit
of another and following that path the
young boy was reunited with his grandpa
one last time it's a beautiful story
following the events here and thanks to
the help of fortune teller Baba Goku
manages to locate the final Little
Dragon Ball brings upper's father back
to the land of the living giving him the
same experience he had when reuniting
with his grandpa moments prior and
before the Dragon Balls fly off I
thought it was a great idea to have him
catch the four star ball and with that
comes an end to both this chapter and an
era of Dragon Ball for the next time we
see these characters it will be three
years into the future for the 22nd
Tenkaichi Budokai
[Music]
normally while I'm reading a story I'll
take a step back part ways through and
try to place myself into the shoes of
the author I'll ask myself how I might
have progressed this story what's the
next logical continuation and the answer
while I was first reading this was I
have no idea we had just received the
payoff of what I consider to be the
story's longest running narrative
through line so far in Goku reuniting
and getting closure for his grandpa
Gohan this had been a question mark
dangling over the Series and won Akira
Toriyama slowly drip fed information
surrounding throughout the story until
it eventually came to a head during the
fortune teller Baba material however now
looking back on this series in this
retrospective review I can identify what
I thought was a terrific choice in story
progression from the beginning of the
story through to the fortune teller Baba
Saga Goku dealt with the consequences of
and received closure for a significant
event in his life through his grandpa it
was a story very much centered around
growth and finding friends through the
things he loved most like fighting these
were stories dealing with Goku's past
and childhood development but this next
one this next Arc marks the beginning of
a new chapter in Goku's life the 22nd
Tenkaichi Budokai isn't about the past
it's about the future and the generation
that are primed to inherit it
immediately what sets this Arc apart
from the prior is expectation we've been
shown how this format works and we're
familiar with all the Hero characters
that are participating in how they fight
and that might sound great and all but
it's actually terrible because there's
no surprise these were the hurdles
initially in front of Akira Toriyama
when sizing up an approach to this
tournament Arc I've spoken in the past
about what I love tournament arcs for
the action for me is very much secondary
to the opportunities it provides the
characters and the journey they go on
within this framework and because roshi
disguised that Jackie Chan led the
charge for the narrative last time in
him effectively being the point of view
character struggling against the odds
it's only fitting that he remains a
driving force this tournament Arc 2 with
it effectively being his swan song but
that still leaves a number of other
characters lacking any sort of surprise
Factor we've just seen Yamcha and
Krillin get benched easily in the first
part of this video and so we need a way
to care about them again well during the
closing moments of The Last Arc they all
come up with a plan of action concerning
the next World Tournament right around
the corner Krillin and Yamcha opt to
train with roshi while roshi
specifically instructs Goku to trade on
his own around the world in the interim
while simple this effectively achieves
two things simultaneously number one it
gives Krillin and Yamcha a chance to
improve their standing next to Goku and
the upcoming tournament and number two
having been effectively attached to
Goku's hip the last while we've become
intimately aware of how strong he is as
readers so removing him from the
equation and skipping forward in time
after the mysterious training Goku's
undergone is another great way to create
anticipation and secrecy surrounding
Goku's true strength level these two
modifications on the status quo
following the Last Arc are important to
take stock of and recognize certainly
but perhaps the most significant and
memorable addition to this Arc is
through the introduction of one or two
characters
[Music]
Yamcha Krillin Jackie Chan the newly
invigorated Son Goku and a nasty
relationship between two rival martial
arts schools in the crane and turtle
groups we've got all these question
marks right before the beginning of the
qualifying rounds this is gonna be a
great tournament the qualifying runs
dashing back onto the scene having just
apparently ran from the other side of
the planet Goku makes his presence known
with little effort qualifying for the
top eight securing a spot in the
quarterfinals the purpose behind his
dominance once again continues to try
and establish in the prior World
tournament that showed Goku not as the
one to overcome adversity but to instead
Empower him and to create a force for
roshi to overcome at this point in the
story this is still very much where our
heads are narratively can roshi do what
he managed to in the last tournament
again can he instill the necessary
philosophy and teachings in his pupil
Goku in this Arc it's also made obvious
that certain characters have grown
physically sporting different character
designs like new haircuts and new
outfits with Yamcha and Bulma making
that the most obvious change however
there are more subtle changes that I
really appreciated too for instance take
this image of Goku after putting his
gion in this Arc nothing to write home
about right he looks about the same as
he did before you might think well he's
actually a decent bit taller the pose he
takes here in this panel is drawn
specifically to evoke memories of an
earlier panel during the 21st Tenkaichi
Budokai wherein Goku assuming the exact
same pose around that same time in the
tournament demonstrates his appreciation
for the clothing compare both of these
panels and you'll see for yourself the
difference in Goku's new older character
design I think what this tournament
offers that the others didn't is a wider
variety of significant things to concern
ourselves with as readers we want to
know what Yamcha and Krillin are capable
of we want to see Goku's new power and
we want to see how Jackie Chan will
contend with the up-and-coming
generation but reading the wrench that's
thrown into this cacophony of conflict
has to be ten chinhan chatsu and the
crane school chansu is creepy the crane
Herman is cruel and tensionhan is the
embodiment of their Collective teachings
and how this individual imposes his will
on all the questions we have concerning
the turtle school is what brings about
the best in the story with him
immediately setting his sights on Yamcha
and chaosu Krillin and because of this
we immediately have something to sink
our teeth into narratively for the
quarterfinals Yamcha vs ten shinhan this
fight haven't been made because 10
shinhan told chaotsu to force the
numbers Fighters would choose using his
psychic abilities is another example of
tension Han forcing his will on the
tournament's activities and while
tension does win this fight he gets the
first indication that this group of
turtle students aren't your ordinary
adversaries at least not the sword he
thought he would encounter here with
Yamcha using effectively his entire
Arsenal as well as a surprise to both
tin shinhan and to us when he produces
an exceptional Kamehameha the
choreography and use of space in this
fight is something else with the
companion fight in the anime sporting
some outstanding animation and artwork
it's clear to see how far everyone in
this tournament has come since the last
one with the level of fighting prowess
on display throughout however in the end
tension hand comes out Victorious
satisfied with the result having thought
Yamcha was the school's best competitor
given his age he sets his sights on what
he perceives to be the only other
Challenger that's worthy of his time the
winner of the 21st Tenkaichi Budokai
Jackie Chun as he squares off against
his quarterfinals adversary man Wolf Man
wolf vs Jackie Chung of all the early
matches that have focused on Comedy
throughout this story I think Manuel vs
Jackie Chan is one of the greats it's by
no means visually interesting or
compatibly close instead it's a short
funny encounter that establishes a
premise plays with it and eventually
pays it off never to be seen again it
exists to communicate a short joke and
it's great at being that I think
essentially this dude manwolf is a
reverse werewolf in that it takes a full
moon for him to turn into a human again
and thus he's furious with Jackie Chan
for blowing up the moon in the prior
tournament allowing him to never become
a human again it seems It's a ridiculous
premise but one that breeds a lot of fun
I highly recommend checking it out if
you haven't seen it shoutsu versus
Krillin this fight right here is where
ten chinhan starts to revamp evaluate
his assessment of these Fighters and
begins acknowledging their abilities in
their own right more so with Goku but
this fight has some stuff too worth
discussing I think this might be the
only fight shouts who participates in
where he looks in any way threatening
Toriyama really leans into his creep
Factor particularly in how he
communicates his sudden and quick
movements that coupled with some
unconventional and never before seen
attacks Krillin finds himself on the
back foot time and time again however
thanks to his ability to think on his
feet and chaochu's inability to do so
Krillin confuses the little psychic long
enough to score the Vic it's not a super
impressive fight by any means but
there's some funny jokes and it really
leans into Krillin being more of a
strategist than an actual fighter pan
put versus Son Goku something I
neglected to mention during Goku's
qualifying matchups was that he matched
with a former winner of the tournament
and in the blinkfani eliminated him with
absolute ease this trend continues with
the character of pan put a prodigy Peg
to be the next best thing in the martial
arts world and with all of the promise
and accolades attached to his name Goku
once again without any trouble totally
dismantles him in front of everyone
securing his trip into the semi-finals
of this tournament alongside the likes
of Jackie Chan ten shinhan and Krillin
what I like about the ending of this
fight was that it mirror attention Han's
qualifying display where all the turtles
Tunes remark of the number of strikes he
lands leading to his opponent's loss in
that same way with Goku's Victory
tension Hunter marks in amazement at the
speed and number of strikes Goku lands
to secure his victory in this moment ten
shinhan recognizes Goku as something
special but he's still not impressed the
semi-finals
these semi-finals are a star-studded
affair fondly Remembered in the annals
of Dragon Ball history or at least they
very well should be featuring fights
between Goku and Krillin and ten shinhan
and Jackie Chan they are both terrific
fights with a lot of narrative and
emotional weight behind them and for me
these semi-final fights are the anchor
of this entire Arc here's why ten
shinhan vs Jackie Chan a significant
driving force behind the actions ten
shinhan and the crane school take is
that of dominance tenchinon has been
taught to crush and has been encouraged
to humiliate anyone that would dare
think they could be superior to him and
I personally think that specific aspect
of his character that character flaw is
precisely why this fight against roshi
is one of the best in the series and the
perfect send-off to the Jackie Chan
Persona a running theme that's been
following roshi like a shadow as he
engages in training with his pupils and
the various Tournaments has been that of
succession and responsibility since the
story began he's been the almost
reluctant holder of the title
responsible for the Earth's well-being
it's a responsibility that's been come
his through the strength he sought to
achieve in his Youth and keeping all of
that in mind it re-contextualizes to a
certain extent his teachings with
Krillin Goku and Yamcha as soon as Goku
releases his first Kamehameha roshi
acknowledged Goku as special and came
out of his isolationist lifestyle to
once again engage with what he believed
to be a promising new generation and in
pulling that thread it led him to this
fight with ten shinhan once again in a
tournament to help Foster the Next
Generation only this time something
feels different throughout the battles
he's witnessed during the build-up to
this tournament as well as Baba and
before roshi has consistently been blown
away by what others predominantly Goku
have been able to do and right before he
goes to face off against ten shinon he
takes the time to have this interaction
with Goku and Krillin concerning panput
[Applause]
all he needed was a little push and he
pushed and shinhan most certainly gave
him this battle is awesome roshi once
again is forced to get serious and throw
at all sorts of tricks to push ten
shinhan until Chen shows him something
he wasn't expecting
the choreography in this battle is
stupendous and what's more is roshi
takes this as an opportunity to try and
convince ten shinhan that his talents
are better served elsewhere punctuated
with a choice from roshi as impactful
and surprising for attention and as it
was for Goku and the guys in the back he
exits the ring leaving ten shinhan with
the knowledge that he did so without
using his full power brilliant fight
brilliant story
not
[Music]
much
[Music]
Krillin versus Son Goku
a brilliant piece of dialogue that
caught my attention was something roshi
said to ten shinhan during Goku and
krillin's fight as well as Ten's
response
this is something I think modern Dragon
Ball loses sight of personally with the
introduction of characters like Vegeta
later on down the line the narrative
flirts with the notion that pride is not
only okay but it's a path that's worthy
of going down when in reality pride is
nothing but the source of Shame and it
is precisely what this moment between
ten shinhan and roshi points out I
honestly missed this philosophical angle
the story would take and its positioning
within the opening of Krillin and Goku's
first ever match was something I thought
perfectly echoed that scene sentiments
as his two students proceed into battle
not with the sole ambition of winning or
being the strongest but to instead test
their abilities against someone they
respect taking all of this in it's
wonderful getting to see roshi exiting
these semi-finals following a loss not
with a sense of disappointment or shame
but instead with a feeling of deep
comfort knowing that the future is
bright with these impressive individuals
leading the charge and speaking of those
leading the charge Goku's fight with
Krillin is something to behold the
camaraderie demonstrated both off and on
the fighting stage is heartwarming but
the respect each competitor shows each
other is remarkable with Krillin asking
Goku not to hold back or he won't ever
forgive him and Goku claiming that this
is the most fun fight he's ever had
impressive in both the Manga and Anime
making full use of their respective
mediums the philosophy surrounding this
fight as I mentioned is fantastic but
once again it is yet another fight that
has some stupendous Toriyama
choreography exploiting every angle and
utilizing some unique uses for the
Kamehameha from both competitors Goku
using it as a booster to give his
punches more power and Krillin using it
defensively to create an opening for him
to grab his tail once again leading into
the Strategic workarounds in his persona
unluckily for Krillin however in the
three years since they last saw each
other Goku removed that weakness and
once that option was removed Krillin was
simply outmatched by the young fighter
Goku emerges Victorious with a nice bit
of writing between the referee and Goku
to cap everything off at the end the
referee says to Goku the next batch is
the championship round would you like to
compare break and Goku responds puzzled
and I don't care Goku very much valued
that fight but it by no means pushed him
at all this next fight should be a fun
one the finals Son Goku vs ten shinhan
the beginning of this fight is filled
with strategy and counters initially
losing early on Goku impressed with
tension's power and toughness decides to
push harder and harder getting into an
apparent advantageous position early on
as tin shithan in the air is primed for
a Kamehameha but Goku chooses not to use
it it's subtle but I love this
indication that he's taken on board
different pieces of advice he's been
offered growing up as a young kid he was
criticized for not thinking things
through and charging in head-on but
right here you can see the strategy he's
employing he's aware that this opponent
is powerful and has the ability to fly
he might Dodge it he thinks this fight
will be a long one and he needs that
energy towards the beginning of this
fight tension hunt particularly when it
comes to the vanishing technique Goku
uses and has used against Krillin in the
past he immediately recognizes the move
from the prior fight and counters it
immediately but as the fight wears on
Goku implements similar applied learning
to the taio-ken or solar flare if you've
seen the dog immediately snatching roshi
sunglasses allowing him to land a heavy
blow onto tension hunt I love
choreography like this it's a massively
fun and I love the pervasive use of
callbacks to earlier points in the arc
and further setting this fight apart
every fight from the qualifiers up until
now have been relatively short lasting
no longer than a chapter or two and so
narratively because this is given ample
time to breathe it feels all the more
significant and huge as a final it feels
like a massive occasion the fight isn't
over in an instant it lasts long enough
to tell a story and for us as an
audience to feel the rhythm of that
story tien's impressed Tien gains the
upper hand Goku's impressed Goku gains
the upper hand but the real overarching
story concerning this encounter and
really this entire tournament has
concerned itself with the struggle for
tension Han's Soul during Roshi's fight
with tension on a large part of it
focused on roshi trying to instill some
sort of lesson in the young fighter
recognizing that he has so much
potential as a martial artist despite
his horrible master and during this
fight with Goku his allegiances are
tested in ways he never anticipated
[Music]
this is an important moment not simply
because it finally creates a moment for
attention Han to distance himself from
the crane school but instead because it
sets in motion a trend whereby the
villains secured their own downfall
personally I love this narrative choice
and it is by far and away my favorite
narrative tool to dispose of villains
not just in Dragon Ball book The Wider
world I first noticed this technique
used in the film Tarzan as a child when
Clayton the story's villain through his
blind hate-filled pursuit of Tarzan
inadvertently hangs himself despite
Tarzan's greatest efforts to prevent him
from doing so it's a simple but
massively effective tool that highlights
the villain's flaws and amplifies the
hero's virtues and in Dragon Ball later
this technique will be used to bring
about the downfall of the series 2 most
iconic villains and right here in
classic Dragon Ball we see the impetus
for this narrative technique Master
crane demands that ten chinhan kill Goku
not understanding his pupil or the honor
he wants to conduct this match with and
despite his screams for murder death and
revenge he gets a Kamehameha courtesy of
Master roshi sending him flying I love
this scene following this tension hun
brings to light techniques Goku could
never have imagined sprouting two
additional arms creating instances where
Goku can't defend himself but primed us
as an audience for swerves like Goku
using his tail as a fifth appendage to
even the odds this is such a fun and
creative fight and honestly it pains me
that we don't see more creative
implementation of maneuverings in modern
Dragon Ball fights they offer so much
entertainment to think that these are
Concepts or relics of a bygone era is
honestly quite sad everyone nowadays
wants their latest Transformations or
flashy beams but back here we had
legitimate strategy using moves never
before seen in the story it makes the
world feel so incredibly colorful that
is until the climax to this fight
for when ten shinhon Bellows the name of
this technique the color is Zapped from
the faces of chaotsu Krillin and roshi
respectively terrified both for Goku and
tension hunt there are so many ups and
downs to this fight at this point it's
clearly the most intense in the series
made evident by the number of story
beats and the fact that the stage has
been disintegrated but narrowly having
escaped by jumping high into the air
Goku remains ten chinhan is drained and
Goku readies one last Kamehameha the one
he saved for such an occasion earlier in
the conflict but instead knowing that
tin shinon has an answer for that
technique as made evident in his prior
encounters Goku once again finds a
creative use for the blast knowing that
he can fly fast enough to evade a blow
propelled by the force of a Kamehameha
Goku launches himself like a rocket
towards the weary fighter they both
hurtle towards the ground and the first
to touch down loses Goku manages to
expel just enough energy to put himself
above tension on when
[Music]
first reading this I was stunned given
the subject matter and philosophy of the
prior World Tournament it stood to
reason that he would likely lose the
21st 10 kaichi Budokai I mean come on it
was his first and that was the lesson of
the outing at the end of the day but to
lose it again for a second time at the
Finish Line I was stunned every fight
leading up to this encounter had Goku
like a Powerhouse steamrolling through
the competition and to have him lose
here albeit in a questionable manner was
stunning for me to read first time
through the fight was incredible it had
some interesting narrative choices and
was the single best visual fight
Toriyama had produced to date in my
estimation but somewhat remarkably this
Arc wouldn't be remembered for this
fight but instead remembered for its
aftermath
[Music]
come on
[Music]
the unthinkable has happened
a terrific tournament has ended in
tragedy
the stakes have never been higher and
the tone so dark everyone it's time
let's defeat Piccolo and save the world
foreign
something I think Akira Toriyama is
unreasonably Adept at pulling off is the
tying of story beats together seamlessly
despite not having prior planning for a
long-term story in other words he's
really good at making it up as he goes
to varying degrees of success of course
take for example Goku's grandpa Gohan
and the subplot contains therein
starting off the story he may have had
the idea of what to do with that
information but throughout the story it
linked Goku with so many other
characters until eventually 100 chapters
later it gets paid off in this fashion
and it's spectacular at the best of
times Dragon Ball can give the
impression of a well conceived and
thoughtfully mapped out story set in
Rich and vibrant worlds populated by
wonderful characters but in the first
chapter of the King Piccolo Arc chapter
135 we see a perfect case study
demonstrating the advantages and
disadvantages of this very Narrative
Approach which haunts the foundations of
this Arc introduced during the fortune
teller Baba material is this line and
with it a sense of foreboding prophecy
similar to the other events in the
narrative this piece of dialogue acts as
a loose piece of exposition meant to
establish the idea that Goku will one
day save the world from a great evil and
following the 22nd Tenkaichi Budokai
observant fans like you might notice
that this event being set up right here
perfectly fits that premonition's vague
outline while also nicely coinciding
with the climax of Master Roshi's
contribution to the series setting him
up for something significant to
contribute to this Arc also
having symbolically handed over the
reins to the younger generation during
the tournament this opening chapter's
strongest facet comes I think
specifically from Roshi's point of view
and the ominous Revelations that are
communicated to us through it after he
realizes who's behind krillin's death
something Toriyama is clearly going for
with this chapter is to instill a very
different and significantly more serious
tone following the comparatively light
and invigorating 22nd Tenkaichi Buddha
the first half of this chapter
concerning roshi is filled with grim
mystery tragedy and history concerning
his former master and the implementation
of the mafaba technique to lock Piccolo
away for good it does a terrific job at
introducing the immediate concern we
have a natural escalation of stakes
following a shocking and emotionally
charged moment it verifies the
authenticity of Baba's premonition and
it involves the participation of roshi a
character that's clearly about to reach
his emotional climax in the series it's
stupendous
story in question kicks off perhaps
better than any other Arc and early
Dragon Ball also it's impactful and
compelling immediately bouncing off the
climax to an incredible tournament and
into something significantly darker than
we've ever experienced before and
fittingly Goku's disposition is affected
tremendously as a result of this sudden
shift in tone he's filled with
aggression rage inventions all fueled by
the sudden death of his best friend
Krillin it's understandable it's
relatable and it puts Goku immediately
on the back foot with the likes of
tambourine thanks to him being drained
from the finals match he had moments
prior with ten shinhan and by the way
these right here the two tambourine
fights they are in my opinion the most
emotionally charged fights of this Arc
and feel all the better for being such
throughout these fights with tambourine
Goku shows more anger and resentment
than we've ever seen him Express and
Toriyama does an incredible job at
conveying that on the page making the
occasion feel all the more impactful and
important there are certain panels that
just by looking at them you can see Goku
oozing aggression and hatred
particularly if you compare them to how
he looked during the arc prior this is
new and in feeling this perhaps for the
very first time Goku acts irrationally
on pure emotion leading to all sorts of
conflict within this narrative which is
a terrific example of character writing
leading the narrative it's incredible
and I love this choice of Storytelling
but it does also have its downsides so
let's explore some that I noticed
Arc made itself known to me by way of
the introduction to the titular
antagonist of the arc King Piccolo
himself and regrettably I think it's one
of the clearest examples of what happens
when toriyama's lack of planning comes
to bite him back within this
introduction both Piccolo and The pilaf
gang in extremely unnatural dialogue
start divulging the necessary
information to us as readers or viewers
they are talking the story at us and
certainly not the intimidating or
imposing sort of first impression we
were expecting explaining that they
found and released Piccolo
okay and that's never explained which is
rather unfortunate and transparent
considering the pilaf gang play
virtually no role in the story outside
of acting as a plot device that allows
Piccolo to get up to date and speed with
the present day's activities following
the visceral rich and Powerful display
of emotion shown by Goku and roshi
moments prior this scene lands entirely
flat totally sucking the air out of what
should be an impressive and intimidating
unveiling of the most powerful and evil
character the series has ever seen
thank you
thankfully however Toriyama seems to
have on some level registered this too
as from this moment on throughout Z
every major villain either gets
established in the ark's lead up makes
it impressive or intimidating entrance
out of nowhere or sometimes both you see
the trouble with villain focused arcs
like these is that the structure of them
feel very well for lack of a better term
predetermined and because of that we
know going into the story that Goku will
meet some trouble early on and then
eventually overcome said trouble to win
the day this isn't something unique to
Dragon Ball it's a very common story
format and so it's how you disguise that
obvious conclusion looming ahead that
makes four great stories I think in the
Frieza Saga we knew Goku would win the
day eventually but we had no idea how he
would manage to pull it out of the bag
in the end and through numerous UPS down
swerves and near Falls Toriyama manages
our expectations for that Arc and its
finale beautifully much the same way he
does with the likes of Vegeta and cell
also but with this being his very first
Arc venturing into this villain format
it very much felt like a traditional and
in some ways Hollow version of what he
would later perform to Greater effect in
Z and unfortunately because it shares
the exact same format it's difficult not
to compare this with the best of Z and I
think that's a good example of what I
perceive to be the primary issue with
this Arc it tells an incredibly simple
story in the most predictable way
possible there's no deeper complexity or
any subversive nature of any sort and
the story it does tell doesn't connect
enough plot threads to feel as
meaningful as I sincerely expected it to
as I said the story from the get-go was
of course going to involve Goku rushing
out to try and defeat the big bad
Piccolo would of course defeat him early
in response to this Goku will gain a new
power or train or something and then
fight Piccolo again the framework is
obvious but there's a lot of room for
interesting storytelling and while there
are wonderful additions to this story to
help break up the main plot thread it
never managed to gain any sort of earned
momentum leading up to the finale
instead opting to leverage established
Masters to create larger tension and
contrived power
throughout this retrospective review of
the series roshi has been a character
that's consistently blown me away time
and time again with not only how
pervasive he is throughout the narrative
but how impactful he can be also the
prior two tournament arcs are elevated
tremendously simply by his presence and
even his added commentary during Baba
enhanced that experience also but in
this Arc his placement and contribution
to the narrative feels a lot less
impactful than I was anticipating it to
be now it's important for me at this
point to highlight a distinction in what
I'm saying I did not expect him to play
a pivotal role in the downfall of
Piccolo directly in fact given the
prevailing narrative throughout I fully
expected this to fall on the younger
generation with this effectively being
his passing of the torch once he fails
to eventually stop Piccolo which I still
feel is one of the strongest points of
this Arc by the way and yet despite
enjoying the history offered by roshi at
the beginning and his speech following
his failure to defeat Piccolo I felt as
though something key was lacking
there was a considerable amount of time
early on dedicated to explaining the
history of and exploring the risks
surrounding the mafaba technique in this
story we've seen glimpses into Roshi's
past through individuals remarking on
his legacy like Yamcha those at the
Tenkaichi Budokai talking about him and
even Corin when he would speak of
Roshi's time spent with him and when we
finally get to see a flashback into
Roshi's time spent training as a young
man under his mentor we learn of the
technique the mafuba a move that
thematically represents the passing of
the torch to the Next Generation a move
he learned from his master and when
roshi eventually passes on to ten
chinhan when he tries to master it in
time to make a difference it's a
wonderful technique that ties into the
villain and it's thematically consistent
with what roshi represents in this
series the adoption of responsibility
it's perfect but it plays little to no
role in The Wider Arc Maybe it's because
it doesn't make for an impactful or
impressive finish to the final battle
but it's the failure of the mafaba a
technique that represents inheritance in
the series which highlights for me the
weakness of this Arc it doesn't feel
like it's connected its plot threads to
tell a greater story nothing roshi does
contributes to the ending of this Arc
besides putting tension onto sleep with
sleeping gas he for some reason has in
his possession and may be providing
greater motivation for Goku after his
death I personally found both roshi and
Goku's response to the news of krillin's
death and Piccolo's influence to be
really interesting roshi pretty much
embodied fear and restraint while Goku
represents naive impulsivity and
unrestrained anger he snapped at Goku
during the beginning of this material
ordering him not to charge an emotional
and totally exhausted and this was
something I thought could have made for
a nice point of connection or contention
between Goku and roshi in this story but
instead this is the last time they share
the screen together and it's at the
beginning of the arc and not just that
Goku almost makes the exact same mistake
again when he realizes roshi and shoutsu
were killed by Piccolo only this time
with no intervention and without any
reason really he stops when corn asks
him to I thought the means with which
Goku's emotions were used in The Wider
Arc were in a word less than ideal and
that despite the clunky nature the
villain of the Ark was introduced with
he still had a phenomenal showing
against Goku one-on-one setting the
stage for what could become one of if
not the most emotionally resonant
conflicts of the series to date
eclipsing what Goku might have felt
avenging krillin's death and the moment
this Arc knows Dives for me personally
comes during this scene with Corin after
being beaten to within an inch of death
courtesy of King Piccolo yajirobi
carries Goku to the top of corn tower
for a sense of being and training this
was a great choice I thought it included
pre-established settings and persons to
further the story making the world feel
lived in but when Goku hears that
Piccolo killed both roshi and chaotsu he
also gets seriously angry while a top
corn Tower this was something I thought
would have made sense to be a
significant moment one that could have
given this Arc some sort of narrative
cohesion connecting all of the
characters together roshi might very
well have lived had Goku restrained
himself appropriately within this Arc
but this facet is never addressed roshi
dies Because he believes that he needs
to do something he's left to take action
in a way he definitely didn't want to
have to do and in a way Goku in his
naive and emotional Outburst at the
beginning is connected to that happening
but that point is never developed on or
explored within this Arc instead Goku
manages to restrain himself in time to
listen to Corin and because of this it
felt significantly less weighty than it
otherwise stood to be in my opinion and
once he does restrain himself the story
Cascades into a battle made possible
thanks to a convoluted and I might even
argue lazy power-up there might be a
connection made thematically between
this risk Goku was willing to take in
drinking this poison water and the risk
roshi took with the mafaba but really
that feels a little forced and somewhat
of a stretch to me and so all in all
going into this final battle despite the
stakes never being higher and the
consequences of the events never
yielding a higher body count with
everyone's fate left in an uncertain
tizzy thanks to the destruction of the
Dragon Balls I couldn't help but feel
that something was lacking going into
the final fight and once that fight does
get underway the Bad and the brilliant
of this Arc are clear as day
Goku vs King Piccolo I think this Arc as
well as this fight have a lot of upsides
the artwork is incredible throughout it
incorporates secondary characters to
some extent like tenshin and najirobi
who is just a treasure that needs to be
preserved I swear the time he spent with
Goku in the forest is always a joy to
read through the two characters are
strangely similar in a lot of ways and
different in others making for this
surprisingly effective fraternal
relationship but yes it has a lot of
upsides and I'm sure it's most
definitely the favorite fight of many of
you watching right now and I think
that's great I can't take that away from
you but for me unlike the rest of this
review Series where I've been pleasantly
surprised by how well all of this holds
up this fight fell a little flat for me
I started this review by highlighting
the fact that Akira Toriyama famously
and notoriously likes to take a more
relaxed approach when writing his
stories sometimes this works out
tremendously but sometimes it yields a
series of choices that feel immensely
contrived for instance let's take a look
at what's needed to happen in order to
get to this fight with Piccolo in the
first place and bear in mind I am being
a little nitpicky here but it's just to
prove a greater point
number one
was released and we have no idea how the
appear how they manage
where did they find the rice cooker
housing him how could they possibly make
this happen all of these questions are
simply hand waved away in the opening
chapters number two the first fight Goku
has with old Piccolo in the woods
alongside yajirobi is preposterously
fortuitous for the young monkey boy the
only reason Goku survives is due to his
heart stopping at the exact moment
Piccolo checks to see if he's alive and
as soon as Piccolo leaves suddenly Goku
comes back to life number three now
completely drained of energy with no
means of transportation he not only
happens to luckily be in the company of
someone he randomly met in the woods but
that random person he met also possesses
the immense strength necessary not only
to climb Korean Tower I think that has
only been achieved by Goku in recent
memory for those concerning it but he
also does so while carrying Goku on his
back and finally number four after
arriving at the top of corn Tower with
the anticipation of receiving more
training Corin reveals that he can't
train Goku anymore but he just so
happens to have a magical war that can
unlock Goku's hidden potential and
Elevate his strength to where he can
fight a newly rejuvenated King Piccolo
Space Jam did this did the same thing as
a gag in the 90s but this is a
legitimate plot point in this story one
which makes the climax possible and
that's hard to get past these aren't
minor plot points that only become
apparent when you look for them these
are major story beats responsible for
every major event outside of Roshi's
portion of the narrative which as I
discussed earlier doesn't play nearly as
larger role as I thought it would going
into it but that's a personal gripe how
does this final fight this climactic
battle between Piccolo and Goku play out
King Piccolo vs Sun Goku the fight is
stunning in terms of choreography on
display despite my waning investment on
an emotional front this is once again
the beginning of what will become a
trend moving forward with strong and
imposing villains leading the charge of
arcs creating magnificent moments and
snapshots in manga history Piccolo
Vegeta Frieza Selen Majin Buu this evil
character type for Goku to focus on and
fight against darts here and as I
mentioned the implementation of ten
shinhan in this final fight both to save
Goku and to add further complications
was a wonderful way to bring some
emotion back to the conflict with it
leading to the stakes being brought to
the Forefront for Goku once again having
to come to terms with the notion that
roshi chaotsu and Krillin are
potentially Gone Forever Goku now is no
longer fighting for them but instead to
prevent any more destruction being done
to the rest of the world which is a
wonderful lesson and sense of
responsibility for Goku to adopt now as
the Earth's primary Defender climaxing
in spectacular fashion is Goku armed
with just one arm left uses the
technique passed down to him by roshi to
take out the greatest threat the Earth's
ever seen and as soon as the fight ends
Goku's face crumbles as he's overcome by
the emotion of the occasion on its own
this moment or series of moments are
utterly spectacular and exactly what I
wanted from the story day one and to its
Credit in addition to Goku's story of
inheritance and responsibility King
Piccolo also has his moment to shine as
he births a new son one with whom he
unloads his own brand of responsibility
one day my son you'll avenge your
father's death don't let the fire of
evil die out
breed a strength of not just this Arc
but really all of classic Dragon Ball
including z it's its ability to
seamlessly tie every Arc together as if
it were meant to be from the start one
large story informed by the events that
just happened and nowhere is that more
true than in this Arc closing off with
King Piccolo following the hatching of
his cute Piccolo Junior there's a
tremendous sense of relief but also
sorrow and lingering dread the best
decision Toriyama made during the
material of this Arc I think at least
from a narrative perspective has to be
the measures King Piccolo took in
destroying the dragon shenlong himself
it was something we never thought was
even an option it landed much needed way
to the final battle with Piccolo first
and foremost but it also created
believable and natural choices made by
Goku in seeking out a means to
circumvent this apparent roadblock with
him effectively still wanting to find a
way to revive his lost friends and
mentor and the best part is is that in
order to reach this new level never
before seen by any character in this
story he has to use the relationships
he's earned and cultivated with other
people he uses the good he's done to
prove himself and this is my favorite
part he has to use a weapon that's been
part of him since day one chapter one
nyobo without any one of these this
would be impossible the magical staff
now provides with it a means with which
to ascend to the next level to meet with
the individual who created the dragon
balls in the hope that he might be able
to provide a way to revive his lost
friends this is my favorite aspect of
dragon Ball's World building this sort
of expansive and otherworldly color
added to the franchise through this
particular way of reaching a new level
we've seen it with Corian Tower and
we've seen it with King Kai later in the
story and this is just another one of
those examples and watching as Goku with
the help of his nyobo soars through the
clouds and into the unknown I can only
imagine the wondrous feeling that filled
the people of Japan when the main
character of this series not only has
decided to meet with God but has also
earned the right to do so the design of
the lookout is awe-inspiring and as Goku
is saying ends the lighter using his
tail to Aid in that Ascension we see a
strange looking figure waiting for him
what sort of Adventures await Us in this
retrospective review well you'll have to
wait and see overall despite the length
I went to explaining my issues with this
part of the series The King Piccolo Arc
honestly felt a lot more enjoyable than
I remembered it being on my very first
read through all those years ago I was
able to cling onto characters of this
story much more readily and to be
perfectly honest if you haven't read it
I highly recommend Goku's first
encounter with yajirobe random as it
might be it's some light and fun banter
between two characters that rarely ever
get to speak to each other but have such
a fun chemistry the story sometimes in
minor and others in massive ways seems
to take shortcuts but as made evident by
the sheer number of people out there
that love this act for all the reasons I
praised it for in this video it
definitely has something to offer and
should not be overlooked even by the
most nitpicky of anime fans it's a key
part of the Dragon Ball story that set
the trend for evil villains far into the
future and one that makes the next Arc
possible
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
last week when I covered the King
Piccolo Saga and described it as Akira
toriyama's first significant dive into
villain-driven narratives prior to that
effort the closest we got to stories
surrounding big bads came in the form of
the Red Ribbon Army and taupai Pie
neither of which were necessarily the
focus of the arc for extended periods of
time with the other arcs in the series
outside of that centered around the
world tournament format seating the show
every single time and with good reason
they're amazing but that's what makes
this Arc I'm discussing today so
brilliant and stand out in this early
Dragon Ball material not only does this
Arc learn from and build upon the
mistakes and narrative beats in The Last
Arc but it manages to deliver one of the
best villain driven stories while also
being the single best World tournament
in the entire Series in essence this Arc
is the culmination of everything that
came before it training with Kami this
introduction between popo and Goku who
was honestly too iconic an opportunity
to pass up so I decided to reach out to
my good friends Kaiser Neko Lani pator
and masuko X to help me introduce this
special character
oh wow this is the highest stuff they've
ever been
Grandpa did tell me God lived in the
clouds oh heck does that mean I'm in
heaven
I wonder if I'll run into him again
uh all right are you God not the one
you're looking for oh well could you
point me to a mister popo Mr Popo could
you point me to him Mr Popo icon But
first you must undergo Popo's training
training
training good then let us establish the
pecking order oh I love chicken
[Laughter]
the popo encounter once Atop The Lookout
is a fun affair with Goku trying to
prove himself worthy of training under
Kami the guardian of the earth what
stands out to me in this brief but
important encounter is that it
highlights once again Goku's endearing
and innocent sensibilities when it comes
to his approach poppo effectively tells
him to get lost because he deems him
weak both physically and spiritually but
in that instant Goku demonstrates his
strength of Spirit by taking that
criticism on the chin and using it as a
chance to train and get better leading
popo to remarks
and through that character-driven choice
made by Goku we learn more about the
lookout and what makes it a special
place to train
ERS
that is what natural Exposition looks
like tying beautifully into the primary
lesson learned through this portion of
the story Goku wastes too much energy
through unnecessary movement and in
learning how far he truly is from their
level from the bar popo has said as a
threshold to meet in order to qualify
for training instead of pouting crying
or arguing his point Goku just gets
excited at the thought of working on
himself to get stronger it's not a
matter of not being able to do it for
Goku there's no self-pity there's no
self-doubt for Goku he sees this as a
matter of time before he achieves his
goal that expression of enthusiasm and
eagerness to learn then acts as the
perfect character-driven trigger for
Kami to remark from afar that he likes
Goku by simply being who he is he has
much like with his prior Mentor figures
gained favor with and access to the
highest Authority on Earth Kami
everything in this section is drift even
by character from Goku charging akami
thinking he's an enemy to kami's
backstory's Revelation all of this
Exposition is dispensed through those
natural Avenues provided by the
characters driven motivations it's
honestly a remarkably efficient portion
of this tale filled with personality
philosophy and lore
and with that comes an end to this
nostalgic early era of Dragon Ball gone
now are the days of childlike adventure
and comedy focused narratives on the
horizon now are battles hardened
villains hell-bent on world Conquest
with the only hope for mankind resting
squarely on the shoulders of the
generation that's been fostered in this
early material right here we say goodbye
to this brand of Goku for the next time
we see him he will have grown
substantially
the 23rd tenkaiichi Budokai three years
later
the editor working alongside Toriyama at
the time kazuhiko torashima as well as
all those involved alongside Toriyama
were very much against this idea of
Aging up the character mostly because it
involved completely changing the
character design of the main protagonist
this wasn't something often done and
certainly not by what was at the time
the leading manga in the industry the
old adage of if it ain't broke don't fix
it must have resonated with more than a
few surrounding Toriyama at the time
however for him it was something he
desperately wanted to push foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
and with baited breath the team
surrounding Toriyama ventured into both
new territory however little did they
know it would Usher in the dawn of a new
era one in which Dragon Ball would lead
the charge transforming from a brilliant
manga to something truly exceptional the
qualifying rounds describing this Arc as
the best tournament in the series isn't
necessarily A controversial opinion
however I think quite a few might
struggle with effectively putting into
words what makes it so special there are
plenty of noteworthy surface level
observations to be made of course the
group of recognizable or fan favored
Warriors participating is larger than
prior tournaments and significant in
addition to us all as an audience being
eager to see what's changed in the last
three years concerning them specifically
Goku seeing as he's been training under
backing order for those three years but
for me I think there's something else to
look at which makes this third and final
Tournament of early Dragon Ball So
Special the 21st 22nd and 23rd World
tournaments of early Dragon Ball are
perhaps the best part of the entire
series when considered a as a collective
contained within these snapshots of
dragon Ball's history is a three-part
coherent and heartfelt narrative driven
by a clear goal and sense of character
the 21st tournament details the
instilling of key values onto both Goku
and Krillin by Master roshi attempting
to preserve their fighting ethic and
cement a philosophy that to this day
remains part of dragon Ball's core
message fight not for status or for
Glory but to better yourself and to
protect others it's elegant and it's a
resilient philosophy the 22nd tournament
then contends with the natural
progression or evolution of that very
idea seen through the lens of a mentor
basking in the Twilight of his martial
arts career both he and we as an
audience discover the latent potential
of this new generation rising up as
roshi finally concedes and passes the
torch onto them this idea then reaches
its natural emotional and logical
conclusion at the 23rd World Tournament
wherein the new generation of Warriors
are tested not just against each other
but by their Collective pasts climaxing
in a refined and mighty add perfectly
integrated main villain to cap off this
era of Dragon Ball in a fashion never
before seen to this level in the series
it's outstanding and it all starts here
the quarterfinals casting your minds
back to the 21st and 22nd Tenkaichi
Budokai quarterfinal rounds you'll no
doubt recall some bouts like Yamcha
versus Jackie Chan or chaozu vs Krillin
but in reality most of those fights were
throwaway bouts that carried with them
little narrative significance outside of
some gags simply a formality that would
transport or main cast into the
semi-finals where they would no doubt
encounter much more interesting
competition Goku vs girin and Jackie
Chun vs manwolf are certainly
quarterfinal fights that match that
billing this is however exactly what
sets this tournament apart from all
those that came before it every single
fight from the quarterfinals onwards
operates on an entirely different level
tying not just key characters together
but producing in themselves stories that
are in isolation tied to the past and in
other cases filled with mystery Tao
paipai vs ten shinhan this tournament is
honestly a terrific manifestation of all
that Akira Toriyama has developed over
Dragon Ball's lifespan utilizing the
qualifying rounds to spend some time
with taupai Pai by taking out chaosu in
a fittingly cruel fashion only served to
build anticipation for his inevitable
fight with ten shinhan in the
quarterfinals with his character
intrinsically connected with tenshin
Hun's roots in the story it made for a
perfect opening to the qualifiers by
closing the book on that part of ten
shinhan's life
[Music]
the story concerning this fight is
effectively Tien coming face to face
with his past seeing it for what it
truly was and moving forward from that
the tale of a promising young man LED
astray by the teachings of a ruthless
Mentor is as old as time itself but when
you house the climax to that very
encounter in a tournament setting you
have for yourself the perfect recipe for
a thrilling conclusion Tau comes across
as Petty psychotic and eventually
pathetic as ten chinhan thanks to the
path he's taken since his departure from
the crane school now possesses more than
enough power to humiliate his former
mentor and yet he shows restraint at
every opportunity out of respect
pleading with him to resign this wound
gesture then serves to highlight the
extremes of both combatants tension
strength of character and tau's weakness
of character in the 22nd Tenkaichi
Budokai which featured roshi against
henshinhan roshi demonstrated a
philosophy which led Tien to ask if he
had any Pride something he himself felt
he needed to rely on someone and in this
fight against Tao Tien has come full
Circle he does not wish to win for Glory
or for to humiliate his opponent quite
the opposite this is a painful Affair
for him and he wishes for his former
Mentor not to embarrass himself any
further it's a brilliant fight that
concludes in the fashion it should
highlighting for us how far ten shinhan
has come as a character and it's made
all the better thanks to the stories
that came before it tenshinhan advances
to the semi-finals next up Son Goku vs
name withheld continuing the string of
iconic quarterfinals matches and another
that's rooted in the past of the Dragon
Ball story comes Son Goku vs this
mysterious female fighter much the same
way as the prior match with ten shinhan
this fight was set up or foreshadowed in
the qualifying rounds and I love it
Goku's reintroduction to the series as
an adult was a terrific and iconic scene
in its own right and it was written in
such a way that allowed us as an
audience to watch on in the know as day
Goku's friends slowly discovered the
person that they were talking to was in
fact the little boy they had once known
it's a fun and playful scene which
focuses on reaction rather than mystery
but this quarterfinals match takes the
opposite approach in its effective and
iconic reintroduction of the character
Chichi to the series and while this
isn't the most complicated mystery I
have no dedicate a few people guessing
leading up to her eventual reveal back
in the 80s this was an impressive reveal
not necessarily because it's Chichi but
because it was satisfying and I think it
achieved this level of Satisfaction by
way of one crucial element that needs to
be present in all mystery reveals the
audience needs to have all the necessary
information before the reveal in order
for it to be satisfying and Goku vs
Chichi achieves this by subtly planting
plenty of hints the first most obvious
one is that of the quote promise she
keeps speaking of that's gone
unfulfilled and her being angry that
Goku doesn't remember it the second
however I love the most because it's
even more subtle it's pointed out later
in the air closer to her actual reveal
but it's present long before then and
that is her accent from the first
meeting in the tournament up until the
reveal she speaks just like Goku with
this thick contrary accent and it's
specifically that aspect of their last
meeting as children which I really
thought helped connect them in the first
place and so it's fitting how it's one
of the indications that connects them
here again this is of course in addition
to a number of other telling lions from
Chichi which by the end make her
identity obvious but it really helped
this match achieve a unique sense of
identity with it effectively being
Goku's proposal as usual the paneling in
action is great and I especially love
how Goku never even touched her in order
to pick up the victory it's a really fun
fight rooted in history an endearing
character writing next up Krillin vs
Piccolo Jr of the four fights that make
up the quarterfinals this fight between
the young Turtle school student and The
Reincarnation of the demon king is the
first to not take from the past in any
meaningful or direct manner like the
rest do which means this fight has to
stand on its own two feet as a great
encounter and boy does it do just that
making up for the lack of history
between these two characters Akira
Toriyama makes this fight one to
remember through inspired choreography
near Falls and wonderfully creative
combinations from the clear Underdog
Krillin and in my opinion this is his
best fight in the entire series Bar None
something I thought was a nice touch
with all of these quarterfinal matches
was to have Goku at least on some level
involved before the 10 shinon fight took
place Goku reassured everyone's
attention on had this in the bag and was
much stronger than Tau with him in the
end being proven correct in this fight
right from the top Goku informs Krillin
as to the strength of Piccolo and to go
at him full power from the start I
thought this was a great choice as it
builds the relationship between Goku and
Krillin with him effectively showing
concern for his friend and lending
advice but it also helps to elevate Goku
in her eyes establishing him as a man
that can accurately evaluate people it
preps us as an audience for later when
he makes more dramatic judgment calls I
really like this the fight itself
between Piccolo and Krillin is
phenomenal it's not the longest but it
does everything it can with the time it
has with the story of the match not
necessarily concerning itself with can
Krillin win but instead can Krillin
prove Piccolo wrong right from the start
Piccolo called Krillin a quote nothing
and in many ways this assessment sort of
rings true for us as an audience too and
going into this we aren't sure if he can
do so much as anything to Piccolo
the look of surprise on Piccolo's face
here is something to Marvel at you can
almost see him thinking oh damn I
underestimated this guy the story of
Krillin throughout this story has been
that of a young kid looking to prove
himself early on this took the form of
arrogance blowing himself up cheating
and feeling deflated when he sees others
succeed where he would fail this then
naturally developed into him using that
element of his personality in creative
ways to help make up the difference
where he could by being more strategic
particularly in the 22nd Tenkaichi
Budokai however in addition to this
development he also was on the receiving
end of numerous attacks acting as a
punching bag for various villains and he
never managed to capture the respect of
any of them he just proved that he
wasn't on their level without putting up
much of a fight at all now of course
this fight between Krillin and Piccolo
comes with some terrific action and not
to mention angles this by the way is one
of my favorite action panels of the
series but the fact that this fight
ended with him having given it at his
all surprised his vastly stronger
opponent and chose himself to step out
with a smile in his face base highlights
perhaps better than any other choice the
sort of growth and development Krillin
has undergone as a character he's gone
from an emotionally weak wannabe fighter
to one that understands his limits
accepts them and works within those
boundaries to do more than his vastly
Superior opponents ever might have
expected leading Piccolo to say I fear I
won't be able to conquer this world so
easily Piccolo does Come Away with the
win but Krillin leaves with his respect
and next is the final fight of the
quarterfinals Shen vs Yamcha what I
would like to draw attention to in this
fight is just how amazing Toriyama is as
a writer when he's at his best these
quarterfinals all have a unique sense of
identity but they can be paired off
thematically also for instance tension
on vs tau is a unique fight with a
specific tone but it shares a theme with
Goku's fight alongside Chichi while
being a mirror image of it tien's fight
sees him confronting a familiar face
from the past forced to put him down
because he refuses to yield Goku's fight
too saw him face off against a familiar
face but not one he remembers much the
same as Tian he doesn't want to hurt his
opponent and in the end unlike ten
shinhan doesn't the differences are here
where Tien hopes to never see him again
cutting ties with Tau and that part of
his life and with Goku very literally
tying the knot with Chichi someone that
will become a key part of his life
moving forward this is a beautiful use
of theme and storytelling to help these
fights flow naturally into each other
perfectly tying the story together and
this trend continues with this fight
between yancha and Shen with it
effectively being a mirror of the fight
between Piccolo and Krillin going into
this The Narrative brings to our
attention the fact that Yamcha has never
gotten past the quarterfinals in all of
the story sort of similar to how Krillin
never managed to prove himself or gain
the respect of a main villain and with
yanch's opponent now being Shen someone
that seems to have gotten in on the
basis of a fluke yamcha's feeling great
about his chances for semi-finals Glory
that is until
now something I intentionally didn't
mention about Shen during the qualifiers
was his elimination of a specific
character to gain the ability to appear
in the quarterfinals he defeated
yajirobi who's now sulking around the
tournament grounds like some sort of
weird Lucha stalker this is clearly no
amateur and as we soon find out isn't
your average ordinary fighter either
similar to Krillin Yamcha find himself
pitted against one of the strongest
fighters in the series Kami hiding
within the body of a civilian to try to
take out Piccolo the reveal of this
secondary plot thread added further
tension to the event's proceedings but
what it didn't do was Elevate yamcha's
situation making him feel like more of
an afterthought and with strike after
strike blow after blow Yamcha is looking
as though he's going to be knocked out
of bounds by the God of this world who
by the way doesn't seem to have tried
very hard at all viewing Yamcha is
nothing but a stepping stone on his way
to fight Piccolo later and this is where
it gets interesting as I mentioned the
story of this fight is a perfect mirror
image of Piccolo's fight with Krillin
both involve winners that hide their
identities to varying degrees for the
purposes of the tournament both enter
their respective battles anticipating it
to be nothing special but both get
impressed by their respective opponents
abilities with Piccolo taken aback
almost immediately and Kami at the very
end
in devastating fashion
[Music]
I don't know what is much like the prior
fight these Pages demonstrating the
initial strike of yantra's energy ball
and the subsequent counter by Kami
exemplify perfectly what it is about
toriyama's paneling that I adore there's
such a powerful sense of movement the
pages almost feel kinetic filled with
life and flow and in the end revisiting
these quarterfinals I was honestly Blown
Away by the level of quality present
throughout with the surprising level of
thought having gone into the encounters
the themes present and Breakneck action
paneling to rival any of the other
tournament fights that came before it
and with the semi-finals now approaching
I think you can now appreciate why I
think the 23rd Tenkaichi Budokai is a
contender for the very best Arc the
Dragon Ball series has ever produced the
semi-finals
[Music]
Son Goku vs ten shinhan in fittingly
grandiose fashion the finals from the
prior tournament are now acting as the
semi-finals for this tournament the last
time these two faced off it was close
but tensionhan managed to squeak out of
victory in the end to win the 22nd
Tenkaichi budakai so how do things
measure up now well the entire fight
while great at its core is there to show
just how amazing Goku has become and I
think tenshinhan was the perfect
candidate to bring that out of the
character similar to the prior fights
the paneling is Stellar with some really
interesting angles and ideas
experimented with but for me I think the
largest contribution this fight made to
the series was the introduction of
voighted clothing in fights
weighted clothing wasn't necessarily A
New Concept of Dragon Ball at this point
as it had been established during
Roshi's training before the 21st
tankaichi Budokai all those years ago
however as I alluded to earlier never in
this way before this is once again
another concept or idea introduced in
early Dragon Ball that will become
exceptionally popular later in z
and Z used to tremendous effect right
here in this scene to achieve one thing
to place Goku in a position of mystery
and control throughout this tournament
no matter what match was taking place in
the quarterfinals Goku would remark upon
each encounter with tremendous insight
and observation skills lending to the
idea that he is more in control and more
powerful than even we as an audience
might appreciate and that very aspect of
the story being told through this fight
is emphasized through this very action
he's been concealing his power from both
his opponent and us the readers or
viewers tension on remarks beforehand
that he's impressed by Goku's
Improvement but that his speed is still
nothing compared to his own leading him
to outmaneuvering Goku at every turn
however despite this two things remained
consistent Goku never got tired and Goku
never had a problem tracking his
movements and this all starts to make
sense when you realize he wasn't able to
move as fast as he wanted to placing
Goku once again on another level above
everyone else which isn't an unfamiliar
position for him to be in during these
tournaments throughout the 21st and 22nd
Tenkai a key aspect of these tournaments
surrounding Goku has been that of how
competent he actually is and the story
surrounding them have been discussing
how best to overcome the mountain he
presents to the likes of roshi and
others however what makes this Arc
unique when taking that aspect into
account is that unlike the previous arcs
where Goku is the obstacle in this Arc
Goku is the point of view character the
hero we see his internal thoughts as he
tries to piece together what's going on
between Shen and Piccolo and even ten
shinhan and Tau and that's what makes
this Arc so special he's not the
obstacle Piccolo is and right now
tenshinan is blocking the way to Piccolo
and that long sought after a first place
spot strongest under the heavens
needless to say things aren't looking
too good for the crane school alumni but
what I really like about this section is
that ten shinhan doesn't roll over and
take this sudden show of ability by Goku
as an indication that he's lost hell no
he's the defending Champion instead in
response to that he whips at a move no
one has ever seen before including Goku
in the past we've seen after image
techniques and we've even seen grow
extra limbs in the prior about three
years ago but this time he takes that to
its natural conclusion by splitting
himself into four separate but identical
Fighters and the presence of this scene
serves two purposes one to demonstrate
how tenacious gifted and hard-working
tension on is as a fighter and two to
show us all that Goku not only has
developed physically as made obvious
earlier in the fight but that he has
sharpened his mind greatly also
so
I really appreciated the angle this
fight has taken it places Goku once
again in the driver's seat and creates
all of this anticipation with his very
statement alone begging us the readers
to try and figure out what those two
weaknesses might actually be that he's
talking about overall this fight
delivers on just about every front it's
a terrific settling of a score produce
some wonderful paneling and showcase
some clever action writing with the
weaknesses Goku exposes in this
technique not only making sense but
because they made sense it only further
cemented how much more adaptive fighter
Goku has become over the last three
years Goku advances to the finals in
dominating fashion next up
Shen vs Piccolo Jr
with one match between two Rivals now
having reached its conclusion we press
onward to another between Kami
inhabiting the body of a civilian named
Shen versus The Reincarnation of the
Demon King his other half Piccolo Jr and
while it's one of the shortest
semi-final matchups its design is simple
but immensely effective these
semi-finals while interesting in their
own ride with some interesting action
set pieces were designed with the clear
mission of establishing and building up
the contestants of the final match up
above all else with this fight against
Shen used to outstanding effect in
helping to elevate Piccolo higher than
we ever could possibly have foreseen
something you might have noticed during
this review however is that despite
having acknowledged Piccolo as the main
villain of the Ark I've not done much in
the way of speaking about him Beyond his
relationship to Kami and that's with
good reason if you were to go back
through the previous Arc and this one to
compare the two incarnations of their
respective piccolos the king and The
Reincarnation you'd notice that while
sharing some ID theological similarities
they are markedly different Piccolo Jr
throughout these contests seems to have
shown some respect to his fellow
competitors on some level during
numerous fights either while watching or
participating Piccolo acknowledges the
power and toughness of his opponents
going as far as to admit what he's being
proven wrong this isn't something King
Piccolo would ever have done with him at
the first sign of resistance pushing
back or losing his mind to blinding
anger however when Piccolo was taken
aback and shown resistance he applies
strategy and counter measures
foreign
the fight itself is littered with some
interesting back and forth with some
telling pieces of dialogue and actions
taken it's an effective fight lending
opportunity to develop Piccolo raise the
stakes of the event and even at times
elevates Goku in subtle ways during the
Shen vs Piccolo fight on the first page
of chapter 181 after seeing the
Breakneck pace of the opening to this
match everyone is left stunned roshi
Krillin tenshinhan Yamcha everyone
except for Goku without words this helps
him stand out from the crowd ahead of
his match in the finals and on the topic
of the finals match there's a brief but
interesting back and forth between Kami
and Goku right before he goes out to
fight Piccolo in the semi-finals and
within it the pieces are set for Goku to
become the character he will remain for
quite some time into Z and Beyond
throughout this series Goku has been a
character that when faced with
expectation and reality shatters those
expectations innovating new ways around
problems people never thought possible
at present Kami doesn't think Goku has
what it takes to do what he things he
needs to to kill Piccolo Jr and Goku
doesn't want to kill Piccolo knowing it
will in turn kill Kami and there my
friends lies the main problem of this
Arc Piccolo has sealed Kami inside a
vial and swallowed it and now Goku is
the only fighter remaining to protect
the world from the wrath of this
Sinister individual but if the last
number of arcs and indeed these last
couple of fights have taught us anything
about Goku is that when he's backed up
against the corner and given two options
he's the sort of character to grit his
teeth dig deep and create a third to
find another way when no one else could
this is what I call a true heroes moment
and it's all coming to a head for the
finals of the 23rd Tenkaichi Budokai the
finals
Piccolo Jr versus Sun Goku of all the
fights in Dragon Ball none other better
signal the rise of the younger
generation more so than this right here
Goku who surpassed his older master and
Piccolo who's just dominated Kami and it
all comes to a head in the finals of the
best tournament in the series it's
established early on that Goku is
fighting with a self-imposed handicap
well okay actually two not only does he
want to defeat Piccolo but he needs to
protect the spectators surrounding him
and in addition to that he still wants
to win the tournament all this time as
an audience we've been focused on
Piccolo and the threat he presents
overcoming him and freeing Kami but Goku
he just might do it something of note
also during this match is that the
battle contains the inspiration for some
of the most iconic moments and set
pieces from Goku's fight with Vegeta
take for example their beam struggle
during the gorge battle it's iconic but
the exact same scene took place with the
exact same framing in this battle with
Piccolo and if that wasn't enough
remember Goku's battle with uzaru Vegeta
one massive difference between these two
battles with giant opponents is how the
scene serves Goku or depicts him for
lack of a better term in the Vegeta
fight as many of you might remember Goku
is firmly on the back foot which
admittedly has its own benefits in
creating additional tension moving
towards the climax but in this Piccolo
fight the science disparity isn't used
to overwhelm Goku but to instead subvert
the audience and prop Goku up and
demonstrate how tough he is and how
intelligent he can be he openly refuses
any help from anyone else like ten
chinan or Krillin citing it as grounds
for disqualification something he's
actively trying to avoid while trying to
defend himself against Piccolo but
perhaps most impressively and what makes
me prefer this version of this set piece
more is how Goku uses it to manipulate
his opponent to create new Solutions
never before thought of when Goku is
faced with a hopeless situation he will
create a solution no one thought was
possible and he did so here not just
with his strength but with his strategy
and intelligence how you communicate to
your reader or viewer that your
character is strong that he's a powerful
individual not with big numbers or
Screaming but showing us first hand the
effort and misdirection he forces
Piccolo to work through it's an
impressive display placing Goku on a
pedestal alongside Piccolo at this
moment it truly truly feels as though
two demigods are duking it out with no
other living being even remotely coming
close demonstrating Innovations on
techniques I didn't even know I wanted
like firing the Kamehameha with his feet
allowing him to free up his hands for a
punch it's incredible the creativity on
display here and despite every thing
that's on the line time and again he's
forced to deny the help of anyone that
interferes now what a great and
impressive part of the story concerns
itself with Goku overcoming the odds and
managing to unleash more and more
ability and power his friends never
thought he had the other half of this
battle is supplied by Piccolo who in
turn shows his own brand of toughness
and grit to push through whether that be
the strength he demonstrates the
techniques he amazes us with or the
secret abilities of his race it seems
this character can create his own
alternative options when all others are
taken off the table and this tough
tenacious Dynamic Piccolo brings to the
table for Goku brings out the best in
his character both need this Victory so
much is hanging in the balance and
despite all of this Goku still refuses
to treat this like anything other than a
tournament and this moment this right
here this is where Goku stole Piccolo's
Soul it's in this moment Goku steam
Rising off of him and closed tattered
after taking the very best Piccolo has
to throw at him remains standing upright
before him smiling what an outrageously
brilliant fight after taking the
absolute best this Warrior has Goku
rallies himself one last time and with
fear in Piccolo's eyes the young man
Sprints towards the would-beat Demon
King Landing a devastating elbow to his
jaw it's honestly difficult not to just
sit back and commentate over all of this
fight the panels surrounding this
section of the manga are some of the
best in this series and even are some
toyotaro himself took inspiration for
his Dragon Ball super manga the poses
are just incredibly Dynamic the layouts
are incredible
the entire story of early Dragon Ball
has centered around a specific
philosophy to not train to win but to
better yourself and to protect those
that are defenseless in the 21st
Tenkaichi Budokai roshi desperately
wanted to instill this lesson in the
young Warrior and in doing so learned
that Goku was something truly special
even when he was a small boy he could
see that there was something outstanding
waiting to be tapped into even back then
it was apparent he wasn't like the
others pushing his master to his
absolute limits in the 22nd Tenkaichi
Budokai and Beyond Goku gained the
responsibility that such power brings
with it not because he wanted it but
because it was who he was and in the
face of that alongside a new generation
roshin hung up his ghee for good for the
first time in many many many years a
young boy was able to stand up when
others couldn't and save the world three
years pass now a young man Goku's limp
body lays defeated on the ground before
Piccolo who's now celebrating his
conquest of the earth and in no more
fitting a fashion as Kami rallies the
remaining Earth's Defenders to intervene
life surges back into Goku
this is what makes Goku special in the
face of certain death without any usable
Limbs and every option taken from him he
still finds it in him to dig deep smile
and invent a solution to the impossible
problems that stand before him no matter
how formidable no matter how terrifying
no matter the stakes no matter the odds
Goku will find a way to succeed when
others can't
foreign
[Applause]
sandwiched between two time skips
contains more passion skill vision and
love than many other arcs in this series
and indeed many other stories I've ever
read I started this video series in the
hopes that it would shed some light on
why I loved this story so much and I
hope I've managed to introduce at least
a few of you to what I consider to be
one of the most underrated stories to
have come out of Japan this was a much
needed enjoyable trip down memory lane
for me I haven't had the best year and a
half but this story definitely Has
Lifted my spirits in times when nothing
else could I thank you so much for
taking the time out of your days to
share it with me I don't know what the
future holds but I'm excited and I hope
I'll see you there
also like to thank TFS for contributing
to this video in the best of ways they
are some of the nicest most
accommodating individuals to work with
and you can find everything from their
personal twitters to their YouTube
channels Down Below in the description